two
what up what
friday august 26th
here we are
2022.
welcome everybody it's friday baby yeah
wow
full moon tonight
yeah so uh we got a great show here
obviously we do
yeah for a change yeah
this is abs last day at the helm is that
right ab you got plenty of flocka's
first time today sorry i'm gonna have to
unleash today it's my last time yeah
and lina's last day in a b spot although
you
technically have your own camera and
stuff still but
but you're in every love shot so
just give me love shot yeah so
yes so i guess you know just that's me
we love your contributions so
shout out
ela's here damn what the fridge
okay
let's see what is this first of all this
orange like velvety thing okay exactly
what you said it is is it is it designer
no just a t-shirt looks designer
and then the necklace you have the heart
of the ocean yeah okay look at this
watch bro is this one of these million
dollar rolexes no
oh
i love that i don't do million dollar
stuff
let's see the boots you've been flexing
on everybody in the office with those
yeah okay let's go
you could you can step on my balls with
those later you can insane stomp some
tattoos
when i come under my foot
stomp on me mommy
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry
yeah this disgusting yeah i know it is
it is gross
uh my beautiful wife ila is here my
partner my friend my helper bo
the call back
today we have a great segment planned we
have set up vr
and i am entering the metaverse yes
really
we test drove it um yesterday
after leftovers and i'm glad we did it
it was actually it was funny it was fun
i got banned really fast like of course
three minutes flat it's not funny it's
actually crazy to say
like i don't
i don't want to ruin it because i okay
but they well you're not planning on
doing that again are you saying dude
you're going to get banned like it's so
funny we're relying on that for being
like 30 40 minutes of content today i'll
do it towards the end please god yeah
the grinch
i committed some grave sin of vr
apparently
and a mod teleported in
and he of course immediately started
talking [ __ ] to the mod you were
pointing at the mod you're like you're
weird are you not allowed to do that
wait are you not allowed to point in
their face i don't know i
i hope to review their community
guidelines he's like yo you work for
facebook he's like no i work for meta
yeah and ethan's like oh don't call it
facebook don't call him
he just [ __ ] banned me
when i started doing that you could tell
his hands just dropped you could tell he
was like
on the console or something i knew i
knew as soon as he squared up against
you you were gonna get banned yeah and
for members funny though a lot of that
footage is in oh you got all that yeah
we recorded all this oh that's exciting
that was that was good they'll be out
tomorrow
thank you a.b yeah and so we're gonna be
entering the metaverse it's pretty fun
man it's pretty good in there i'm gonna
be inter
acting
with the people of the metaverse
this is
mark zuckerberg has staked his whole
life and reputation on this
i'm making meats now it's just pretty
easy
so there there's that and also i want to
say
yes we are talking about andrew tate yes
he's in the thumbnail and i this is my
pledge to you guys that this is the last
one
what a [ __ ] liar shut up the thing is
i was thinking about not
we were all like let's not talk about
andrew tate
but here's the thing
we've covered this story
all the way okay and now we here we are
let's just follow through to the end why
should i jump ship right before the end
you know let's just follow through
because andrew tate put out a video
his final goodbye where does he put it
out he had to put it up on like his on
some random website and he had all these
other influencers tweeting it out
because that [ __ ] is so do you platform
he couldn't post it himself
no one will hurt me
oh vimeo bro he's on vimeo i'm gonna say
vimeo is a joke did you really yeah it
was vimeo there you go what you're
posting on vimeo your life is over
that's so like
15 years ago or something yeah dude and
so
i want to watch his video of him crying
and begging for forgiveness and
gaslighting people and then
uh basically that's just the bon voyage
and also he was on tucker which is
pretty incredible did you know that
no i actually had a fire tweet about it
i didn't even realize that
it got so many likes until i checked it
last night
but i don't know if you know this either
but you are
married to somebody that
posted a tweet
that got
306 000 likes so i don't know if that
changes your opinion of me
oh yeah professional poster damn
he's i said so brave to have the sex
trafficking violent misogynist r-wordist
on
because tucker the clear doesn't know
anything about him he's just become like
a right-wing martyr which i love
tucker says who is andrew tight banned
by every platform in the world but not
us
we'll talk to him thursday night
so
yeah it's just super brave of him to
to have him on i mean they're doing what
nobody else is willing to right it's
awesome
but when they go to cancel you ladies
and gentlemen
wait what happened didn't he say he
couldn't be canceled a b
oh i have those actually oh yeah cancel
me i do not care i don't care how did
you do it now he's complaining that
people are complaining about me
canceling him he he literally begged me
to do it
no one can damage me what are you
talking look at he's crying about it
right now
i exist outside of the matrix bro you're
on fox news what are you talking about i
don't even have a [ __ ] account what
are your new banned me you don't even
have to count
it's so good yeah you guys don't
complain that i'm talking about andrew
tape because this is what it's all for
yeah
we've come to the best part of this
story
thank you baby and let's just enjoy it
together okay so no complaining please
with peace and love
but when they go to cancel you ladies
and gentlemen he even looks more beta
for some reason
he got he got cancelled and he just his
neck shrunk
his chin shrunk i think it's just that
now he has to like be on other shows so
it's like different angles yeah he
doesn't get a flattering angle for sure
not his like powerful angle that he's
used to read
it comes hard and fast
you lose your facebook then your
instagram then your gmail then your
audio is only coming in your website he
didn't lose his gmail he's gmail their
audio is only on one channel
well that's tucker for you yeah top
shell in the world right there
i hope it's not your we tested right
before the show though your laptop is
fine i think it's just videos
oops yeah
well we have both channels so whatever
fox news get on our level it's called
stereo [ __ ] look it up
hosting your domain name
like then your payment processor then
your bank that like it's just like in
real time you're watching your phone and
apps just exploding
he's just got cancelled everybody when
they go to camp everybody he got dropped
by everything that's how the putting his
bank
not his bank but his processor probably
did cancel him that's why he got he lost
the whole hustler university oh okay
well that's your business but he said
cancel me so i don't understand
no banking no bank
oh wow he looks just like him even the
angle well you got your bugatti just go
cash it out there you go how do you repo
bugatti i wonder because you gotta
usually
be pretty careful i wonder if he even
has the bugatti anymore
well i look forward to his videos on
vimeo about it
those are going to be huge of course
so so that's going to be fun we're going
to we're going to watch that a little
bit later
lots of good stuff okay and no
complaining
thank you peace and love
when does our audience ever complain
what about anything or when do they ever
complain yeah no they're a
happy-go-lucky bunch
yeah never ever that's some sarcasm no
no
um the most positive
supportive fan base here oh hey gabe
what's up
hey what's going on [ __ ] it's just
friday
houston i was just starting the show
what are you doing
[ __ ] i'm just standing this bank of
america crap
they're giving me a hard time
[ __ ] oh yeah i heard you i'm
angry
i'm angry with something i got out i
blasted on social media if i have a
problem or find something complain
that's what i feel
yeah i heard that gabe had a problem
with bank of america and by i mean i
know bank america sucks i always hear
that they're the worst bank in the world
oh they are
uh
what so what happened yeah what happened
you got this letter and i think what it
said if i read over correctly
it says based on
delinquency derogatory public records or
collection accounts
or credit those are
they just put that there that's you know
that's that's [ __ ] to every letter
they do that to every letter you know
they i haven't used my card in a while
since february because i had a they
charged me they charged me a lengthy
because i forgot to pay him just like
one minute one minute before before the
deadline they charged me the slight fee
i had to complain about it and they
won't do nothing about it so how much
[ __ ] how much how much was the late
fee
like 29 that's [ __ ] bank of america bro
i'm not doing that [ __ ] anymore with
them
[ __ ] i pay off my card and that's it but
i'm not going to use it unless i have to
and then they just close my account
they just lost my account just because i
don't use it oh oh they okay so so let
me so let me just talk to you so
this is your main checking account
credit card account at bank of america
no i don't do that anymore i even had a
problem with them before that credit
card thing happened so you had a job
yeah
i had a checking savings account and
then
and i had i had a better offer with you
know
chase and then
and i decided to close back work i these
these people are just scumbags they are
they are they're vultures
so what happened you had a credit card
with them and then they just closed it
on you
they just close it on me because i don't
use it well that's [ __ ] up dude
people i i i had the same thing with
capital one i don't use the card yet
they gave me a credit line increase
oh so shout out to them right that's a
good one yeah shout out to capital one
and curse and curse on bank of america
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] one time one time i had to put 20
out of their atm because i had an edd
debit card they gave me a
a chair 20. so i i went inside the bank
and then they they want me to go on the
end of the line like just to exchange a
20 they gave me a ripple
what the [ __ ] wait what was wrong with
the 20
it's torn
oh they give you a tour 20 a day
that's [ __ ] up that's insane and then
they made you wait in line for how long
i i i think where you want i had to
complain because it just it's just that
you just give me a 20 idiots
that's crazy yeah yeah i never i never
had a problem with chase yeah i use
chase they're okay they're i don't have
a problem with them either to be honest
they're actually nice the only problem
is they use your card and they've got
the client and it shows fraud protection
that's done that happens a lot to me
yeah i guess that's a good thing though
right they're looking out for you
oh yeah exactly so what happened with
bank of america where did you go to use
the credit card and then it got declined
or something and you got embarrassed
no i'd have an east bank of america you
just got this letter carson yeah can i
ask you a question
if you don't use it how come you're so
mad about it
it's it's not it's just how they treat
me you know i don't know no i don't use
it anymore the principle that's the
principle [ __ ] them bro
[ __ ] bank of america
because i i guess they i gave them an
attitude and then they just decide to
close it it's like one thing they risk
reserve the right to refuse service to
anyone so if you go in the store and
then you give them an attitude they kick
you out same thing here i want to watch
you posted this video uh to twitter this
is all about war on bank of america here
let's watch this one gabe uh bank of
america worst bank ever [ __ ]
[ __ ] bank of america worst customer
service ever
worst bank ever yo is that a teddy fresh
hoodie it is
yes my [ __ ] man
fresh teddy fresh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so did you go to um
a new bank would you have a new bank
recommendation for everybody
well i would say safe city city bank
anyone else really huh yeah
yeah so if you guys if people who have a
bank of america account
what do you say to them
well i won't say nothing i don't want to
hurt their feelings of me oh i i can't
really say you know it's just oh my
opinion that's all right okay that was
nice very respectful that's nicer than i
expected smart yeah i was gonna say
close the account and tell the [ __ ]
bank manager
white clock gabe sent you sent his
regards [ __ ]
do you want
i did that long time ago
yes so we're going to throw
are we going to throw a brick through
the window or not
why
i don't want to i don't want to get in
trouble and get arrested
smart
are you allowed to go in there have you
been like banished
no i i'm not like banished from the bank
i just don't want to go there and then
people say oh this guy's crazy
i love you i'm sorry that bank of
america has done you so [ __ ] dirty i
mean scum scum scum at the earth man
[ __ ] whoever whoever trained these
people to do stuff like that [ __ ] they
should be fired yeah
i should say fire these people yeah the
management
i think it's top down i think we got to
go from the ceo down i think it's we did
a whole restructuring after this
they should fire fire the ceo whatever
you know so we're calling we're calling
here today for the
we need to oust the ceo and all upper
management of bank of america what's his
name down let's do a call out
who's the current ceo of bank of america
let's see
i got it
so we're talking about this guy brian
of course of course his name is ryan
his name this this is our this is our
enemy
brian
moyen what kind of
moynihan
okay brian moynihan you [ __ ] with the
wrong guy we are demanding your
immediate resignation now
[ __ ] do you agree get rid of this dude
if he's
doing stuff like that treating people
that's not good no no [ __ ] [ __ ] such a
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ]
all right gabe well we're gonna do our
best to get justice for you okay
all right all right
it's friday though that's the good news
it's friday it's friday baby
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] baby [ __ ] [ __ ] piss in my ass
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
pissing my ass
[Laughter]
it sure is
shave my head and punch me in the face
[ __ ]
yeah shame my head [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] head shave my pubes
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
maybe i feel better
no i'll have brian do it shave my nipple
hairs brian [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] ryan [ __ ] [ __ ] brian [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's his name huh
yeah [ __ ]
all right
all right good [ __ ] gabe have a good
weekend everybody have a good one all
right love ya
[ __ ]
i still love easter my man
[Music]
the change you filthy [ __ ]
interesting
wow it's such a pleasure isn't it
it just sets you off right
and it's just not right what they're
doing to him he doesn't deserve that
i
mean
what's the chance that mr brian will
actually watch this uh
probably a hundred percent yeah we're
gonna twelve podcasts in the world
so mr brian if that is your real name
you need to do something about this
white claw gabe google him
he's now your worst enemy
uh white claw gabon cameo guys if you
want to support him
love that man let's get that let's get
that
let's get a bank of america regretting
that they ever lost that account
yes sir by the way this is pretty
exciting i don't know if you saw this
hila
youtube added a
podcast
and we're number one on it
no way yeah
like here let me let me see if you go to
youtube and then
where do you see it it's on the left
side
uh you go to the uh freaking
explorer page or whatever like right
now and it's on the back ain't nobody
going to that man what are you talking
about it's a primo spot uh-oh that's
like the worst spot wait where are we
recommended is us we're all over it
we're all up in this [ __ ] i don't know
leftovers at the top on the top right
right i guess it's all based on like
what happened philip defranco not doing
a podcast why you put him there
and then and then i saw this nightly
news
are you gonna turn this into another
like yeah
how the [ __ ] that nightly news
nbc a podcast guys
are we going to really do this again
philip defranco skinny legend not a
podcast
he has a podcast he has a podcast but
this is not yes
yeah another nbc news what the [ __ ] you
talking about wow also i got to say i
don't understand the playlist thing like
i don't know who's clicking this like oh
let me just watch 250 podcasts from
season 4.
recommend it i do like this we're number
one
people in the chat are saying you should
look incognito
it's the same well here let me do it
because
that's easy enough
um [ __ ]
one second here guys
it's a lot of clicking
there's all kinds of extra tabs that dan
added here for some
dance fall that's
all right podcast
let's see oh we're out dude we're
[ __ ] out i'm looking at it's right
there
on popular episodes where are we
right it's nightly news twice
it's nbc nightly news twice we're down
below though
jordan peterson
okay and jordan peterson of course who
the hell knows are these increases oh
that's the episode where he was that's
yeah yeah we're talking about the
shattering episode how are you gonna put
us down here we're live with 28 000
people right now
you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] i mean that
episode is really
just such a
literature
maybe
maybe youtube doesn't like me calling
them [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] and [ __ ]
all over the world
you haven't done that in a while look
i'm not number one recommended 1.6 000.
who are you
[ __ ] you
who are you ramsay
28 000 i'm not number one stop
am i getting too much about this yeah
maybe oh we are number one though on
popular podcast comedy
full send is not comedy i'm gonna have
to ask for a resending of that
who said full send is comedy
it's bro science we've laughed at it a
lot
that's true
by the way interesting i saw that full
send had
what's the difference the board ape guys
on
the ak i mean
there's been a lot of dialogue about
since we talked about the board eight
yap club being
like a nazi
dog whistle but i'm still on board with
it to be honest
they've done a lot of uh
pr to try to lessen that yeah bro they i
even saw like a chat log with richard
spencer who's like the head of the
how would you describe him dan
he's a white nationalist he's like a
leader
he's the grand wizard i don't think he's
really a leader i don't think he's
really that relevant
well he's a known figure in the
alt-right and everything he's probably
most famous for getting punched in the
face at a white supremacist rally well
we love that for him i am of course
a white supremacist
yes so
um
you were saying with the board apes and
him oh yeah i saw a chat log with
richard spencer being like yo no they're
definitely nazis
i was like okay oh well oh he said yeah
richard spencer is like no no they're
based they're definitely nazis
okay
so here they are doing trying to do pr
and stuff but you know what man
i'm not buying it
this guy's giving me goobler vibes
isn't that um
gargamel is that gargamel
uh yeah i think so
doesn't he look like
and forgive me bro i'm just joking
around so if you're watching this don't
feel too bad but you do look like a nazi
[ __ ] experimental
you know what i mean little trench coat
he puts bleach in their veins to see
what happens he looks like the guy whose
face melts in raiders
dude
yes pull that photo up man what's that
character's name raiders of the lost ark
that's more following right and right
this guy
looks like a [ __ ] nazi
and here we're gonna prove it and this
is the most damning evidence we have
is that he looks just like this villain
from raiders of the lost ark who was a
nazi
gg
no [ __ ] re you follow um
[Music]
there's resemblance you're not gonna
give me that glasses yeah the glasses
i'll take it take what i can get
well also they're talking in elk boys so
nazis there's that
[ __ ]
yeah that's it i'm on a tangent now but
anyway congratulations to us
congratulations to us everyone
wow
we did it
by the way dan is this you
why do you have your hood up and [ __ ]
you look like the [ __ ] una bomber
today
i can't get comfortable in this office
because it's it's never it's always
either too cold or too hot and today
specifically my seat is directly under
the vent for the ac
wearing a tank top i know
are you pumped are you cold lena
yeah she's comfortable [ __ ] you dan
dan do you have your fan running right
now i do it's blowing right in my face
why well if you're cold turn the fan off
i'm trying to strike a balance here
there's a lot of factors to take into
account all right it's survived though
parties i kind of like this look well
thank you i'm going a lot the unibomber
look by the way uh cam faye
let's listen
litzinger donated 200 she said i'm in
love with your art cam would you be
willing to sell me an original damn
grand second time what's up dude uh i
mean i don't really have many originals
outside my sketchbook
you could probably commission something
right sure yeah you don't take
commissions cam you should uh not really
but i mean i'll
yeah uh
we'll get in contact with you yes
message on the mob you guys can work
something yeah i'm nervous about talking
about that yeah thank you cam you are
thank you you are mega talent cam is too
pure
cameron is very nice i mean
he's wearing a laurel today did you see
that no i'm just leaning into the joke
now
yeah it looks like a mid-summer yeah
happy mid summer
happy mid summer everybody
oh next friday we have pokemane coming
that'll be fun yay on friday yes friday
anybody on the crew have any thoughts
hmm
any thoughts i'm a huge uh pokemon fan
i'm very excited oh thank you baby well
you why you're baiting love no i was
just curious if anyone on the crew had
any thoughts about it love are you going
to be cool on friday or you're not going
to embarass me
you know you have a little
you guys are pushing the same meme i am
just a big fan of her that's all what do
you what's your favorite yeah exactly
what's your favorite thing about her
just that's a [ __ ] sense it's being
entertaining right right right
okay dude
okay dude
anyhow what's the next
just be cool bro that's all i ask yeah
yeah of course just yeah
thank you man appreciate that
god bless um are we gonna ask her to
take a picture with love through the
screen
like standing next to
we should we should yeah i mean she she
noticed the photo when i was talking to
her she said she thought it was funny
uh let's see what else we got here
uh
we've got uh
here's a train wreck warning his fans
not to gamble when he's on stream with
drake he just hit 2 million yes
this man gambles all day right
slot machines and so he just hit 2
million
and stake you know this is big gambling
company they hook them up with drake now
they gamble together yeah
i'm losing do you understand i am down
millions
guys please do not be dumb do not be
stupid do you understand
do not be dumb asses do you understand
the way i play the way i gamble
you understand even looks like his house
got smaller
he's like [ __ ]
all right [ __ ] downsized from this
gambling [ __ ] look at this badass crib
he's like
it's just yeah it's the same the blinds
are close okay
this is this is after that the first
clip is him playing with train i mean
with like drake
it's awesome man
i play the way i gamble
you understand even with the bitcoin
i've made
in my own career the money i'm in on
twitch listen it is not doable or
sustainable unless you're a large
streamer
that can get paid do you understand you
will lose every time do not gamble it is
entertainment only you understand
entertainment only
you're i don't care if you think you're
in a shitty place if you're desperate if
you think you ca you know at this point
you can just take the it's a win-win
because if you lose it can't get worse
it can get worse do not gamble
you really can't
does he have a uh affiliate code
somewhere on screen does that work
like where's his affiliate code love i
don't see it i don't think he has any
affiliate codes on his stream
but he has one
i don't know i don't know i like i know
he's
actively trying to not
promote it
it sounds weird but
yeah
he's not incentivizing playing i guess
here he is with drake
hitting 2 million congratulations buddy
yeah what the [ __ ] drake is sitting
there like he just bought like a
200 million dollar
boeing airplane right yeah so i don't
know if you've if you've been following
but drake is like so in bed with steak
his whole online identity has been
completely bought by steak why so they
must be paying him some unfucking godly
amount of money
i don't know why how it could even be
worth it for him honestly or for how can
they pay so much to make it worth it for
him oh these people are straight crook
they [ __ ] curious out of money bro so
we were talking about money the other
day and we were saying probably
percentages like he has to get a big
percent from them could be yeah but
these guys have billions of dollars of
[ __ ] untraceable crypto i mean yeah
these guys [ __ ] money dude it's all free
all they do is run software man and take
people's bitcoin it's like zero overhead
and they don't pay anyone out either so
that's even better
but that that looks good i can't see the
11 11
11.
right according to our opinion they
don't pay anyone else yeah that's a
legend thank you that's definitely a
legend
baby that's what i'm saying
holy [ __ ] two points
yes we do
yes we do bro that was 2.2 easy wait
yeah yeah yeah
i looked away for a second was there a
cut here or is this all one continuous
thing where he's like don't gamble bro
don't gamble no no it's a different
video okay that would be so funny
but it's that is what happened about
what i mean that is
so what's the difference really
wait i am confused that there's no
affiliate code because that'd be kind of
a big deal for him train wreck twitch
there's got to be one under there i
remember
yeah it was a long time ago it was like
a year ago that we were talking with him
and talking about all of this but i
think during all that controversy he
stopped showing his code well that's
good actually
that's a that's a that's like a good
faith yeah i i don't remember the
details exactly but i remember something
with the code specifically and uh yeah
he has no code yeah um
well that yeah and that's good that's
that's good but then so that stake just
pays him to stream on their website then
probably yeah and after every big win he
plays a
video saying don't gamble this is all
like uh
like literally two minutes you know what
after every big win you know what plays
that clip it's a lot better than what he
was doing i'll say actually so what was
he doing before well he was just
gambling and he had like a an affiliate
code so people were going and signing up
with this it was like a whole funnel
right leading people into this casino
and now as you said he's like don't
gamble it will ruin your life and all
this but he doesn't have an affiliate
code which is probably the primary way
that they drive traffic there so
that's interesting
it's good that he's saying i agree yeah
i actually agree there's always going to
be someone that does it i feel like and
he he being the biggest one and
like trying to prevent people from
signing up while being sponsored i guess
it's something yeah but drake on the
other hand he is
he is shameless he's all in baby oh yeah
he's doing like giveaways if you sign up
to steak right now you might win and
stuff like that if you deposit fifty
dollars you'll win it's that's the kind
of [ __ ] that they used to do why is he
doing that
i have no idea he's they got to be
paying him
tons of money
he's probably making like 10 million
dollars a month or some [ __ ] maybe even
more i don't know
but with dr it has to be to make to make
it worth it for him the guy is like a
mega
i he has so much money he's worth almost
a billion probably if i guess let's not
talk about making money okay thank you
ty
yeah he well this says he's only worth
260 which doesn't make a lot of sense
because he has a 200 000
200 million dollar plane and a 200
million dollar house yeah his house is
insane
so
well i'm not sure about it a lot of pop
stars live beyond their means and get in
trouble for it so
the things that you're describing might
actually explain why he's doing the
steak thing because he might actually
need the money more than what's the
mortgage on a 200 million dollar house
right
yeah i'm seeing 250 a lot as well i'm
saying he brings in 70 mil a year
estimated
mamma mia
that's a spicy meatball
yes so i don't know it's so different
when you're an influencer like train
wreck though and
you're you're held so accountable for
every stupid little thing and sometimes
it's like way too much like we get way
too much [ __ ] and held way too harshly
accountable
but on the other hand you have drake and
like mainstream media people like him
like they can do anything because like
they're never faced with direct
the direct criticism that you get doing
something like this
so he's just out there chilling for
steak it's incredible man
it really is
yeah [ __ ]
i'm glad he got a good camera set up
though
that's what i'm saying baby that's what
i'm saying
holy [ __ ] he got a really good camera no
you got it
has he been there the whole time
yeah no this is his camera
200 million
bro what no they got
no he they got him hooked up man where's
the boying webcam
they hooked them up big time with this
and i appreciate that steak take care of
their people
[Music]
i'm trying to zoom but be legit there
the whole video yeah yeah
yeah i'll go back
yeah oh my god
that's my that's my like that's my luck
right there but that that looks good i
can't see the 11 11
11.
that's what i'm saying
holy [ __ ] two points
yeah dude also that mic is awesome it's
clipping at regular volume
they take care of the people at stake
you know he set up they made sure that
it's crispy hd
they're getting their money's worth down
here no wonder nobody watched him stream
we were talking about how drake streams
and gets like
ten thousand i think he's offline you
can't even see him yeah they're like
why do i wanna watch someone talk with a
shitty mic yes we do
yes we do bro that was 2.2 easy he
probably likes it like he's like make it
as damn as possible yeah he's
embarrassed
[Laughter]
i'm sure they fight with snake about
this like dude you gotta put on some
lights
pretty fun stuff there okay but shout
out train wreck
i like what he's doing shout out
i like that he's not doing it apparently
he is still making like one to two
million dollars a month from
them so his warnings are clearly not
having the effect that he intends
but he's doing he's making a good faith
effort here it says do not gamble you
will lose
i love losing do you understand i am
down
millions
i love it man that's the crappy place
after he wins
yeah it's awesome
i see so it just like auto plays that
when he gets it
so weird it's like
it's just it means it's just a cheeky's
little thing so he doesn't even have to
say it every time he just plays that
clip yeah he has like a edited video and
he goes to the bathroom or whatever and
displays that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
ultimately you know
yeah i'll say this
it's good
but ultimately he knows it's not doing
anything or not enough if stakes still
paying him a million two million dollars
a month so he could be
he can be as good guy as he wants you
know it doesn't make a difference
in fact the problem is inherent and what
he is doing yeah and that's not going to
change but i don't know and when he says
he says it will ruin your life and then
it cuts to him in his penthouse
apartment hanging out with state we're
hanging out with drake right yeah
it'll ruin your life you'll hang out
with giant pop stars and he did say i
have a penthouse view he did say in the
video i will point out that you will
only win and have a and do well if
you're like a big influencer and they're
paying you
you did say that yeah yeah i mean
that was always as much as we can say
but it
none of that is good it doesn't matter
yeah so it's kind of silly for him not
to be as good guys possible because like
for optics that's the best thing he can
do for himself
especially considering it doesn't matter
so you could say yo i will literally
[ __ ] kill myself if one of you guys
deposit any money i will end it all if i
find out one person to positive money he
could say he could go as far as he wants
and it's not going to make a difference
right
so it's kind of an interesting little
game they play over there but it's
better than it was
i like i think that going as far as
being transparent because i didn't pick
up on that but the fact that he
admits to the fact that he's only even
able to do it because they're directly
paying him to do it yeah because that
was like our biggest criticism
at the beginning of this whole
controversy you were really going in on
them of like
is this is giving a totally false
impression that you're g they're not
gambling with their own money they're
gambling with the house money which is
obviously different than gambling your
own money so and when he says i don't
know that he like made it that clear
he's very upfront i'll say about train
wreck like when he came on the show he's
like i'll just be straight up they pay
me two million dollars a month okay so
he is very upfront
about it
you know he's as up front as he as he
can be i would say
but
i'm not sure i believe him when he goes
we've i've lost millions because i don't
think i don't think
he's losing anything on stick i don't
think okay it's probably technically
true because it's money that
he's paid by stake to use on their
website yeah and then all the money
money to them right exactly so like
it's it's technically true though like
he was given that money and could have
just pocketed it
but yeah i mean his contract probably
requires him to gamble it so yeah it's
not really his money i don't know it's a
little it's a little if he went in there
with all of his bitcoin and lost like
five million they they make they make
good on them
you know what i mean
well anyway whatever shout out to train
wreck who was doing a little better
also another other news
jake paul is fighting or not wait is it
jake paul no it's wait ksi
correct
is fighting
tomorrow right maybe
uh yeah i believe so let me double check
not with ryan cavanaugh by the way
right count up can brian kevin be like
you watching my press conference
yo
yeah it's tomorrow
yeah but k uh fouseytube is fighting
ksi's little brother
and deji has famously lost every fight
he's done which is like four in a row
but so it's fousey yeah so it's fizzy
fousey fought one epic fight where he
had he had to get facial reconstruction
surgery
yeah so i don't i've never seen
either of them in person but i feel like
deji is
bigger
based on my i'll show you online
assumption i'll show you the win but in
my opinion
like fousey is gonna [ __ ] kill him
really fousey has been like
he has got like i gotta see them next to
each other dude he's gone like off the
rails with this training [ __ ] it's like
scary
yo in the amount of beef jerky heats
that's like lean protein yeah
that's gonna set him up for success
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
kushi's taller he's a lot taller
we've learned that that makes a big
difference
dude if they're mismatched like that and
they're trained the smaller guy i feel
like
almost just not fair yeah it will almost
never win
if i could just point out like
you know i'm so proud of taking part of
the crater clash and ian was so right
you know anissa who said like you don't
have to have all this cringe fake beef
for it to be entertaining and to sell
tickets and since the creator clash i
feel like more people are starting to
notice how
cringe all this is right this one is
just like different levels because like
deji's laughing you just gotta watch it
i know i don't spoil it but let's see
[Applause]
is probably saying yo let's have a good
fight
[ __ ] love you bro mad respect he's
like let's order food
it tastes like beef jerky let's get a
pizza after this let's get some beef
jerky beef jerky it tastes like beef
jerky see everybody all anybody's
commenting on is uh fousey's beard which
is all i can really focus on too it's uh
you like it it's really full it's very
full
too full it's
do you know do you think it's died
it looks like do you get advice from
keemstar on how to well we know food
tattooed a hairline on so we know like
cosmetic
adjustments is definitely in his
wheelhouse right
somebody said it looks like he's wearing
a mask
yeah like a coven mask
interesting beard i've ever seen in my
life
i want to feel pretty cool i wonder if
that will protect his chin is that fair
to have a beard that dense
like in a way he probably has to shave
it right
i'm not no no
you can't have a beard that bit that's
the straight-up cushioning dude he's
wearing a mask
no that ain't right
if you consider the gloves it's all
about the force anyways you know of
impact dude dj needs every advantage you
can get are you kidding me
i say
that's cheating
they just do that
yo these guys are about to kiss okay
yeah it's so cool almost as you can see
it is all business no games the talk is
wait are they supposed to be talking to
each other because they're just staying
okay these two are ready to go at it
we're gonna save it
i like the way the guys worked together
before they pulled them apart they were
like you you ready let's go
the boy so who's training more [ __ ]
he's an insane dude isn't it who's he
lost
away in an insane amount of time
um
let me just say that we have before and
after pictures but he got in shape
really quick
this is real because he seems skinnier
when i see him training he's not like
this jacked
that's real yeah that's real
from when to win
i think it was a year difference i've
been seeing a lot of year videos
[Applause]
something happened
[Music]
[Applause]
that was not intimidating it was more
like a monkey call or
like a puppy who misses his mom
yeah i swear it sounds like a monkey
calling for
his family or some [ __ ]
just heard that in the zoo
please don't make that racial you guys
you guys are wrong it literally he
literally sounds like a monkey okay
in fact sound bite that okay
[Applause]
yeah okay all right so everyone's hyped
everyone's excited oh ian just dropped
oh this is awesome yo
fousey said he gave up masturbation for
this
whatever he just
he's a semen retention boy oh [ __ ] what
is this i think that's an andrew tate
thing
andrew
i heard people talking about how he's
into semen retention
uh i like to take away my anxiety take
away my depression
do i need to say it's too loud
[Music]
i've never felt better in my entire life
i've kicked all antidepressant
medications out of my life i don't touch
weed i don't touch alcohol i don't
fornicate i don't masturbate whoa i
don't take anything like i'm sober off
life right now i'm gonna land i'm
feeling better than i ever could you
know i yeah sometimes they take it too
far like i like when they're
i like certain things like i don't smoke
i don't drink that's good obviously
there goes i'm off my meds yeah i was
like whoa whoa whoa whoa that's not
something you celebrate you don't need
to do that take them yeah yeah yeah the
meds are good i'm off anti-depressant
yeah dude no
i'm i'm not fornicating i'm not
masturbating bro
i'm not gay no more
right
remember foozie had that speech where he
said i thought i was sad i thought i was
fat i thought i was gay
oh he said that oh right how about that
classic
so what he's not gay no more
so he goes i'm off my meds
i'm not having gay thoughts anymore
okay
this is why we need a pride minute
because people like fousey shouldn't
feel ashamed to embrace who they are or
at least
i understand the social media
yeah oh here it is
what we're gonna do yeah here
oh remember uh remember her no
uh jenna marbles
and floola who's in every [ __ ] thing
i always talk about how flu is in
everything
how's that guy in everything i don't
have a problem with flula but he's like
a relatively small creator and he's in
every [ __ ] thing dude
every award show flula
a few years ago yeah still still
popping up
no
i uh i randomly did a gig for him like
seven or eight years ago and you know
what that's right it was at youtube
space
so like
so even back then he was he was very
much in he's been riding the wave for
like 10 years i mean the man listen he's
probably a legend and he's funny and
sweet and nice but like there's other
people in the world he was really fun to
work with actually yeah he seems like a
really nice guy man but flute isn't
everything bro he's the shack of youtube
right
it's on his mouth
you
you can go to like 45 seconds
[Music]
yeah this music might be you guys
this is uh
steamies
the steamies uh
2006. he won creator of the year
entertainer of the year
16.
yeah 2016. all right let's listen most
hated youtubers on the platform but i
got to hear this whole thing come back
first off i want to dedicate this award
to the dof brubra as the best family on
youtube
second off
this year i became one of the most hated
youtubers on the platform
that's maybe because i let ricegum punch
me in the face or maybe because i came
out and said 99 of the pranks on youtube
are fake
but i want to say this for a long time i
looked at myself in the mirror and i
based myself based on what i read on the
comments i felt worthless i felt ugly i
felt gay i felt bro
what is that hey so is he using it like
as a derogatory yeah definitely yeah
which is even funny i felt gay how old
are you bro thank god so he doesn't mean
i think i was confused about my
sexuality no he's using it as like a way
to demean his previous song whoa bro
what the hell
bro
hell nah in front of all of your peers
you decide to be hateful like that yeah
i felt like a big gay loser
i felt like a big gay dude who probably
likes dick what an idiot loser
you said he tries to backtrack yeah yeah
it's great that was [ __ ] nice
for a long time i looked at myself in
the mirror and i based myself based on
what i read on the comments
i felt ugly i felt gay bro you can't say
that
i can't believe it's so shocking he was
doing good man super inspiring
i felt gay man
[Laughter]
which is [ __ ] i'm not gay
yeah pride minute for booze
i say this for a long time i looked at
myself in the mirror i gotta sound bite
that too zach come on where are you
and i based myself based on what i read
on the comments i felt worthless i felt
ugly i felt gay i felt that no
like that just based on what they told
me
[Music]
and i'll just be honest a lot of these
people here are probably lgbt yeah i
mean it's a whole crowd of people you
know and none of them will be yeah
no but i think
there's like a whole clique of um
but she's bi i think or or queer lily
sings
stay cut to her huh you get her reaction
what i read on the comments i felt
worthless i felt ugly i felt gay i felt
that no
they told me
but i reminded the country
so he says he says no no offense that's
just what they told me
so what are we trying how are we trying
to get out of this
he's saying people were calling me gay i
think that's what he's trying to say yes
yeah yeah yeah
i'm not gay no more but he chose to say
is it their chance that he's confused
about his sexuality and that's what he
means
i think it was a slip up
yeah i got caught slipping
yeah
for a long time i looked at myself in
the mirror and i based myself based on
what i read on the comments i felt
worthless i felt ugly i felt gay i felt
that no he was like overcome with
passion
but i reminded myself the two most
important words of my life that i had to
use for myself whenever i was fighting
my mental illness those two words are i
am
because everybody's not gay
tell yourself every day [ __ ] i am not
gay
it inspires me every moment to push
forward
i don't know who's gay
i just know fousey ain't
that when i looked at myself no i didn't
say i'm not gay i mean not there's
anything wrong with it but
but just like people said that i don't
know
that's just what the people said that's
what i mean people people don't call me
gay and nobody says that not there's
anything wrong with it at all
so who is gay
the mirror i reminded myself i am
powerful i am strong i am confident i am
beautiful i am worthy
and i'm good enough to be on this stage
tonight so every night i wanted to quit
because one of the comments was telling
me that i should leave youtube for
whatever reason i believed in myself
okay beauty is
isn't what we have on the outside but
it's who we are as a person on the
inside and as long as we all embrace
this gay i think or maybe i'm wrong
whatever i don't need to matter i'm sure
there's a lot of gay people there
can we get a list of all the games yeah
it's a creative space like mid 2010s
that was
i just remember at the time there was a
lot of like gay creators like yeah
they're oakley yeah you know whatever
yeah panda heart yeah so i'm sure
they're all there
certainly
exactly believe that in ourselves then
you have no idea how beautiful we all
are on the outside i'm happy and proud
to be in the room with all of you guys
right now a lot of you look so confused
but i love all of you guys thank you so
much
a lot of you look so confused
oh thank you uh thank you for someone
did a gifted member
but i can't scroll oh here thank you for
the gifted i felt pride for a minute
let's have a pride minute here for
fousey
guys uh set the timer please now
eli i don't know if you've participated
in a pride minute before um
jordan peterson said pride month is too
much pride day is too much so we've oh
that's what it comes from so we decided
one minute of pride where you can be
proud be yourself express your true self
it's okay you know you were born that
way there's nothing wrong with it
rainbow's in the chat baby it's as it's
as natural as breathing the air okay
so
just be proud you deserve love
you know you deserve
rights
you deserve to exist
and and and don't let anyone [ __ ]
tell you otherwise
no matter who they are with your parent
your friends your priests
and if you are struggling with your
sexuality you can't wait until the day
that you're happy and you accept
yourself right
and so i am not gay i just want to say
all right minutes up yeah okay get back
in the closet idiots
[Music]
back in the closet with you freaks
no
he really had to go and say that it's
too much
jordan yeah he did he he was like what
what what's what should
what's the i lost his voice
what's the deal with you actually really
got it good this week i was listening
really when you were like oh i got his
uh
the way he says things and you were like
oh
yeah yeah yeah really good yeah he has a
cadence that kind of figured out
what's the deal with pride month
you need a whole month
what's the deal with what's the deal
with that
yeah he literally said we just need a
pride day isn't that not enough well he
also said remember when pride was a sin
oh
yeah a sin [ __ ] you now we have a whole
month dedicated to pride what's with
that precisely
yeah so happy pride minute uh but get
back in the closet you [ __ ]
animals
shame on you
uh 50 bucks from junita in the last few
apps i've loved how ethan and ila plus
the team have argued against tate's
freedom of speech [ __ ]
there's a short comic called oh the
paradox of tolerance by karl popper that
perfectly summarizes how absurd that
argument is
what is that yeah i saw i saw that
comment it is interesting it's called
the paradox of tolerance
and it's just about how like
nazis who operate in bad faith who their
whole existence is intolerance
will tell people who are advocates of
free speech or you you're intolerant you
need to tolerate us
so it's like a paradox do you tolerate
the nazis who are intolerant
right
or do you you know say [ __ ] [ __ ] these
people and don't tolerate them so the
point is like you need a health you need
a healthy measured amount of intolerance
for the intolerant
i think is the conclusion there two
negatives make it positive let's go
there you [ __ ] go it's math there you
go quadratic formula
it's math transitive property
well so
my favorite jordan peterson moment this
week was yeah we were watching him on
that pog oh my god that was so fun that
was my favorite moment of this podcast
maybe i was just like i was loving it
i'm glad to hear that it was so fun and
then every time with the reading the
comments it was so funny yeah yeah yeah
shatteringly insightful conversation
thank you jordan you know what's my
favorite part about that those are the
comments in all of our videos now who
cares what you believe i think like
there was a bunch of those on the tim
dillon one
and i think he
he doesn't know the meme so right
he thought people really thought that
but maybe it was that and that's that
so it's like you know in ship in
pinocchio
he's made of wood
and every time he lies his nose grows
cut them off it's just like that
so what do you do with that
and so you're doing it wrong
how's pinocchio supposed to turn around
with a long nose it gets stuck in the
doorways
it doesn't make any sense and so when
you think about it like that
it reminds you of the 12 holy the 12
wise men
that walked with george with the jesus
jesus was a good man oh and then he was
talking about the dragon the dragon yeah
i love that
i just i can't the dragon this stuff is
too funny but when you think about what
the dragon represents
it represents chaos
chaos what are we going to do without
vodka like and the lion king when when
when they got stampeded his dad
mufasa mufasa got stampeded
i cried
[Laughter]
all right
little little 300 thing there yeah
like that let me tell you about vodka
nice
yeah so you we should do we don't have
any ads today by the way so teddy fresh
always of course if you guys are into
this peanuts stuff this shirt's nice
it's fun
comfy
it's got a bath too um
who's got the beach ball
gary klein
my dad
yeah so do you guys want to do the um
meta now or should we talk about andrew
taint
um
the meta is a lot more fun
but yeah it we don't know exactly how
long it a lot lasts so
if you want the tate thing not to be
like two hours into the episode you
might want to do that first i don't care
let's just do the let's do the metadata
that'll be more fun did you let us get
it ready
did you guys ever talk about how meta
and hebrew like did we talk about that
what is it
it means like that
it's like
so
kind of an ironic name they chose for
themselves
yeah like they died
that's probably gonna be coming true
here pretty soon
so i will be entering the metaverse
now what i've learned of the metaverse
is that
i had this idea that it was like this
big virtual world
it's nothing like that you join a lobby
and you just join a
room with like 12 people and that's the
[ __ ] what the metaverse is this is
what zuck
changed the name to he has put his whole
reputation on the line
and it's like it's just like third life
second life
it is the third life
the third life
how much money they've spent
so far yeah so let me introduce this a
little bit
uh
metta has spent over 10 billion dollars
on this [ __ ] oh god
the with the price going up year over
year shares of the company are off 38
over the last 12 months
well that's happened to everyone to be
fair
while the s p 500 is down five percent
okay never mind it's bad for him that's
very bad how bad is it they're down 38
their stock that's catastrophic
let's go let's not talk about making
that that's really bad actually let me
see meta
stock
today was another
tanker man
four percent down today man
look at this [ __ ] you want to see this
oh that is not good
wow most social media platform has
really dropped twitter too
well twitter doesn't even have a product
kind of but let's look at uh alphabet
because someone's gotta be dude that's
not looking good either
oh that's yeah that's not that bad it's
not as bad
okay whatever [ __ ] mark zuckerberg
anyway
[Applause]
so their company's hurting this is his
big moment to shine
here's a promo photo from last week by
the way
i don't know if you saw this they were
publicizing it quite a bit
you can do a tour of uh paris now ela
with cutting edge text why does it look
so stupid and how
like how is this the best they can do
what are you talking about this is a 10
billion dollars making their whole life
on this this is the meta
look at the details oh my god look at
the detail my god there's freckles
yeah
yeah so i'm planning to do a tour of
paris today
among other things
uh zuck
wait i wonder who's the creative
director is it actually zak himself
because you know they have probably like
all the talent in the world working for
them wait is his instagram really zuck
yes yeah it is
what the [ __ ]
is he leaning into the meme or has he
always been zuck
his
is that con is his instagram is zuck
i told you
i should have been getting his
you trying to suck how's it what the
[ __ ] i thought you guys were trolling me
with that zuck thing
he posted was it always his name
do you guys know i think he's always
good
major updates to horizon and avatar
graphics coming soon
i'll share more at connect also i know
the photo i posted earlier this week was
pretty basic
it was taken very quickly to celebrate a
launch
oh he's backtracking
the graphics just like you have to
imagine all this like really talented
people they go to college they finish
their
ba best and brightest the best graphic
designers they're like i got a job at
facebook awesome parents are proud
yeah and then this is this this bro this
one this is what they [ __ ] churn out
look mom
i made the sims from 1999
remake
yeah he says so i know the graphics are
bad
but they're coming they're going to be
even better guys
this is the update i guess which is the
sims from 2003.
so they're on track here
they probably showed him really cool
ideas and he was like nope
i have a vision he looks like a wee
avatar
that [ __ ] came out a long time ago
yeah so there's that
here is zuck demonstrating the metaverse
now i'm gonna follow in his footsteps
you know how people do pilgrimages to
israel and they go to nazareth to follow
in the footsteps of jesus
the jews yeah so that's kind of what
i'll be doing today what's up
uh here we go
oh my god
i can't get enough of this man
imagine you put on your glasses or
headset and you're instantly in your
home space why is he so desperate to the
face of the company let someone else do
this just listening to him talk for one
second just let someone else do the
charisma don't don't try to sound
inspiring right
we know you're pretending you're a robot
you're imagine
trying to tap into his emotions chip
it has parts of your physical home
recreated virtually it has things that
are only possible virtually and it has
an incredibly inspiring view of whatever
you find most
so bad painful
it looks like you're standing on a green
screen i mean beautiful
hey are you coming yeah just gotta find
something to wear also also why is he
pretending
why why is he trying to act hold on i'm
coming like at least i mean if you want
to be the face you got to be yourself
but they're not even giving an honest
representation of the avatar he's in
there as himself he needed to let us
know that he had friends who want to
hang out right i think this was a really
elaborate way of telling us that zuck
[Music]
there he is oh [ __ ]
yo
you can wear that yo you can wear silly
outfits in the meta bro all right
perfect
all right perfect i choose not to of
course oh hey mark hey what's going on
what's up
oh hey mark space oh hi mark hi
mark
now you know that this character the
person who with this vr headset is not
really floating right
i just want to make that clear
hi mark
oh hi mark also when i set this up i
made your avatar or whatever there was
no option to be like a robot or wear
funny outfits or anything dude the
customization options were dogs
they are dlc's you have to pay for later
we did this yeah probably we did a
little more work uh
and i think we got our avatar as about
as close to looking like you as
and so there's and it's it's there's
basically you can choose between fat and
skinny
and like five different faces right
cam's actually in there right now if you
want to see what your avatar looks like
now
uh this place is oh let's see here's my
avatar you guys made for me yeah
it's okay it's not bad found a beanie i
found you know a colorful shirt he's
wearing shorts you can't see it in that
but he's wearing that that's pretty good
that's pretty good is that the best
facial hair can you add a beard yeah
well we wanted to do mustache
but you still have like a lot of stubble
so that was kind of the best compromise
i see the options are very
very limited very limited yeah
so um should i watch more of this so
let's see
i mean this is an old video this was
just kind of refresher i think we
actually even reacted to it when it
initially happened well let's go guys
do we have some electronic sounds oh we
sure do in fact we have a graphic right
ian take us take us away
and uh you got some like cyberpunk music
i i i did i did i definitely did you
remember that music i showed you i
remember
jam to it but now i'm trying to click on
it is it not working okay oh there it is
that's not the right one that's not the
right music oh [ __ ] it just go for it
[ __ ] [ __ ] it go [ __ ] him
watch him
can i run to
oh yeah we're loading here look at the
screen look what we're on right now
[Music]
oh yeah you're you're in
all right so hold on let me uh
mute your mic
go ahead and talk ethan hey sound fast
okay we're getting you again
[Music]
it looks great
[Music]
are you guys ready for me we are ready
we are ready all right wow it's like
looking in the mirror yeah you can kill
the music baby thank you yes how this
works is you set up like a virtual wall
so you guys set it up for me right i'm
not gonna crash yeah okay so i see
here's a wall yeah here's my perimeter
yep and i'm on camera the whole time you
sure are okay awesome so that's [ __ ]
great
all right so
where should we begin we're in the
metaverse you guys whoa
crazy guys so good
what's this
what can you guys see all this yo this
is my house bro
this is nuts
yo that fire is crazy
oh
it looks so real i thought i was going
to burn my hand
oh careful it's hot coming with that
heat
yes so
as you guys can
see the plaza is where i was yesterday
should i start there
yeah uh just remember the plaza was the
one that you got banned from um i think
because it's kind of the starter one
it's heavily like there will be a meta
employee there so uh well let me ask you
this dan yeah if i get banned from the
plaza i can still oh wait no no no no
you got banned from the holy spirit you
got banned from the whole thing for two
hours and so right
that would have been great if i could
just move on to another one i'm trying
to click uh can i get a click in here or
do i need this it's the trigger it's
it's the back trigger that's what oh i
see i see it yeah yeah there you go all
right let's go
jesus all right i'm gonna have to mix
the [ __ ] out of this
oh how's the lob sound it sounds fine
it's just uh it doesn't handle the
screaming as well as the broadcast mic
so i'm just gonna
juggle you a little bit scrum less
please yeah less screaming than typical
i'm getting zapped in
oh my god
here we are we're here you guys
so this is interesting like you think
it's this big open world
incredible
uh oh you did me walking i like the
teleport one better oh i thought you
liked the like the walking okay well we
could switch it back if you want you
should be my girlfriend so so here we
are in the metaverse they can hear me
right they sure can like they sure can
yes so yep that's right
you would expect it to be this big
beautiful open world but it's just a
little [ __ ] shitty place that guy
there's a mod that's a mark
alert am i right
am i allowed to curse in here excuse me
yeah uh as long as you're not gonna fit
towards people okay great
so i can cur okay thank you mod can i
ask you other questions
yes you can come over here
okay great great great this is
interesting
so
so you work for facebook
i work for meta oh meta that's facebook
right same thing
well there's virtual reality labs which
is also numbers can we hold hands
division from a meta oh
can you see that dan yeah we're seeing
everything baby how are we saying that
whatever you see we see
are you swearing an oath on your heart
for me
are you strumming a guitar
what are you doing oh you can't tell
what i'm doing no well we could you're
doing something weird i don't know what
you're doing anyway you're back maybe
you have a data pad
yeah cool did you work in like a little
do you work in like uh
like at home or do you guys have like a
whole vr facility
[Music]
hey can you guys keep it guys stop i'm
trying to have a conversation with the
moderator sorry about that
no
client i know you no you don't recognize
them all right i gotta get out of here
yes i do don't ban me
don't ban me dude
[Music]
can i say [ __ ] wait just don't add
people not add people as long as you're
not like insulting someone with it oh oh
okay
so [ __ ] you is offline yeah this is
awesome
uh
back up
can you get these guys in line i mean
you work for facebook can you get these
guys off my nuts
not facebook this is the future baby
bro
bro you want this
what's up you don't have nuts because
what's
can you do something about this guy i
mean this is that this is harassment
everybody listen if you click on
someone's username
it'll bring up their profile
and then on the top right there's three
dots you click on it you can select
you'll never know i got time for this go
get out of here
stop back up
back up
are you allowed to bar are you about to
bark at someone that seems aggressive
man
hell nah yo can we have some respect you
know like
kevin smith in the building silent bomb
oh it's uh kevin smith let me try again
dude
maybe maybe let's move on to quieter
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
state or not
we want to keep security tight just
because some people like to find people
oh
that's weird man
zip code
[Music]
because we're friends i could do i could
get away with [ __ ]
[Music]
no no if you do something i think it's
violating your line i'm gonna remember
i'm not gonna ban you no you wouldn't
coward dude don't stop dude
he has too much respect for me
stop it all right i'm gonna leave i'm
gonna leave i'm actually not subscribed
i'm a big phillip the prank with him
though
[Music]
put it down
don't follow me please
don't follow me what are you going
anywhere oh yeah
yeah we learned about the black
basketball you can shoot it from
anywhere
and it goes in the hoop yeah yo what the
[ __ ]
what'd i say what i say
you guys should play a game
play a game
be friendly i want to shoot the
basketball here play basketball game yo
ready
this goes out to the real one
the spirit of kobe
papa
kobe bryant
rest in peace to a legend
bobby
that was terrible where'd the ball go
i'm a monkey
somebody's giving you a ball can i get
the black one though gosh
oh why do you man get out of here
all right what should i do i should do
something else please
go to a different room yeah go to
somewhere else music oh you got your
blog
oh [ __ ] oh my god oh [ __ ]
you got it you made it it went in oh my
god that was awesome
all right one more time
wait did someone take it
or is that me you're good you're good
you're good it's you all right
guys
there's one man
there's only one man other than me that
can make this shot
his name kobe bryant
his name is not kobe bryant
kobe bryant kobe bryant
yeah
brian ethan klein is is damaging kobe
bryant this one goes out to you brian
watch it watch it watch it yeah that
went like so good miles in the air
dude
wow nothing nothing but net
that's incredible yeah hey man you're
making you're a guy it's called the
spirit of kobe
called the spirit of kobe he came into
you thank you
wait how do you do the finger thing i
can't do who is this guy
i think if you can jared let over though
you can
go like the triggers on the side and the
back are like one on the back of the
connection oh you're almost doing that
you're almost doing it
no i think they don't let you do funny
things
says everyone even wait for tonight come
to me oh i have a question can i do
cyber in here no
so you're on there you know oh can
anyone give me an asl
location
stop oh
there's a mod right there
right next to you
right here the guy you were talking oh
you're a mod
no no no the guy you were talking to
earlier
i'm just a person
are you ready hang on can i ask you a
question hi aaron
hang on
are we allowed
[Laughter]
can i ask you a question yes would you
like to cyberpunk
oh my god
here we go ethan asking if he can have
cyber sex with someone hey walk with me
join me in here hey hey wait wait wait
hey i
oh what
no come to the break room hey if you go
oh wait where'd my homie go
yo talk with me where are you where's
the mod and thingy was trying to take
you somewhere he went to a purple
building i believe oh break room thank
you guys right here where do you go the
top oh you went up to purple before you
do that i want you to have a seat okay
good good good good
now we have a little bit of privacy
finally so oh boy how you feeling
oh i'm all right i am leaving a few
minutes okay okay that's unrelated to
you
bonnie
what are you wearing
yeah you're glitching out pretty bad
right now
actually i just put this on like five
minutes ago so i wasn't really sure
okay okay
oh yeah you wanna see that goes in so
you have interest outside of uh vr or
oh it came out instead
like from right up here okay that is one
of my favorite animations
oh it's one of his favorite why don't
you take off your shirt and get a little
more comfortable hey stop what i thought
[Laughter]
no the shirts are not removable oh can i
take a zipper with you
do you know okay
but you're not wearing pants i like that
you're right i'm not
oh yeah
nice
nice shorts
daddy nice
probably got a hog
stop
you know it jumped
right
now
[Music]
all right let's go play a game or
something
thanks guys
thanks everyone you've been great
bye
see you that much that mom's a great guy
you should try to find it everyone's
getting fired
hey bro you're not gonna get fired for
this area
[Music]
uh i
can't possibly imagine why i would yeah
yeah i think you're fine he's good he's
good yeah he's good he's good yeah
let me ask you this you sexually assault
someone oh my god oh thank god
i'm just curious because that's the
story that oh my god i've heard oh my
gosh
shot everybody
thank you
for the warning
no that's because you didn't know and
that's what you had got the word no no
no no i didn't know i'm sorry
[Music]
i was apologizing i was on my knees and
hands
thank you brother it looked really weird
all right good guy really i like you man
all right peace guys
suck is definitely going to happen
you think they could put a sniper [ __ ]
like iro ethan there's some games in
here
i don't want to play with people that
know me we should go all right so here
i'm gonna i just muted uh their world
um
ian take it off the screen because then
it'll be too easy for people to follow
him
okay so what you need to do is click on
uh
the kind of menu button on there
like that yeah and it should bring up a
menu and you can pick a different world
but i just don't want to show that on
screen so we're just we cut to a card
for a second
are people enjoying this oh yeah okay
good
they're still hearing us too i just i'm
just covering this so that you don't get
stream sniped what you're my favorite
bro i'm starting to do [ __ ]
you're talking about are you still
arguing with people someone's in my face
wait so i'm trying to do top 100 but it
doesn't click it
you see this
uh
that's what it's supposed to be right
yeah you're hitting the trigger yeah
yeah no you're not
there's too many buttons on this thing
yeah look at this this guy's being
obscene can you see him we're not we're
all i'm not saying what you're saying
mod
i missed the vlog with that one
moderator hey hey
uh mod
i need you this guy's assaulting me oh
god
he was doing finger
yeah remove
yeah he was doing finger in the whole
thing there you voted him out he's gone
he's gone
he was doing finger in the hole to me
i do you want me to unmute all right let
me um you can function right
sorry i you were muted i can hear you
know like where you're back in the same
place i explained mutings
to you
right beside is another function called
block you can
make that person disappear and never see
them again well you think they did
something against the roof
poll yeah you kick him out right who
initiates that
looks horrible
it's true there's also the the democracy
to remove what do you mean okay so you
can do finger in the hole
come on this place is
like this
yeah look at that look he's doing it
again well all right so now there's
i think he's doing sign language no he's
doing finger in the hole
it's how i communicate are you
discriminating against me you're using
your voice right now
all right let's let's don't be all right
take it take off the screen again so we
don't get uh sniped here thank you all
right there's a uh there's a um comedy
club one that dan thought would be funny
yeah the comedy club was uh interesting
if i if you uh i don't really want to
play like a game i want to just interact
yeah if you go to 4u the tab for you
okay
i uh i bookmarked a number of them they
should pop up in just a second
so the plaza is where you are and then
there's party house that sounds dope
well don't don't don't say them out loud
it's not party house
other one i mean you can whatever you
know
it's inevitably going to happen anyways
let's do a comedy club this one's really
interesting
it's already full so what are you going
to do
either it's just fun are you enjoying
this yeah okay all right
if it gets boring just say i mean this
isn't a podcast after all
kilo left like 15 minutes ago
[Laughter]
that's just sound bites that you're
interacting yo
there's a 150 000 cash prize
go win it wait from now until the end of
august you can enter pop jam
nope can you tell me what is that
horizon competition
welcome uh these aren't sure
welcome
welcome
all right you're in community standards
violations two horizons
who's complaining respect the house
rules
i think that's an automated message
please report why is everyone all grayed
out i think it's still loading their
avatars
so so guys
we're the comedy club man that is a wild
look okay cool
boom that was weird
what is who is ooh
[Music]
hey guys otherwise why not
what do you mean
you think you're funny is that what
you're doing this is a comedy club yes
no i'm not funny at all and i don't
think anything okay okay bye all good
you know stop being a hater hey hey okay
all right 59's okay are you funny
59
are you fine
what
that's my joke what was it oh i missed
it damn it
you missed that [ __ ]
why don't you get up on the uh on the
stand and do some stand up no racial
slurs well that's gonna be a problem
just kidding all right so how do i do
this someone's up here now someone's up
there now but maybe you can
step up and sing yeah
oh it kicked me off that stage oh yeah i
think you need to uh sign up
yeah
oh how do i do that that's interesting
they're giving out prizes that's so
interesting
top three most importantly
i think you have to do this first check
in someone has to do man this [ __ ] sucks
get applause credit is that a baby
how old is that
i have to buy to do it oh wow
welcome to the future yo i gotta pay to
go on stage somebody's yeah with the
beanie yo you guys you
this actually sucks why did i buy a
quest all right i'm going to buy it
wait hide the screen maybe it's just
going to show yeah
come over here
oh we don't have a payment method in
yeah are you guys serious
why did i buy a question how was that
baby in the middle verse
how did it get there pay for that
he was born there he was born there
four minutes for free baby
what yeah
okay thank you guys thank you thank you
thank you open mic
wait wait it says remove this is just
like a scammer oh okay okay there you go
what is it what do you enjoy your three
minutes i think it's it you can those
are for applauses
why would i buy applause that's the
saddest [ __ ] i've ever heard i think you
can walk through
i think i think you can get up on stage
oh
no no
maybe it's not your turn yet
up now
let's go let's go let's go up next i
didn't say anything i got to sit down
yo this stuff's stressing me out bro
press the button to sign up i did it
already right like i think so yeah
hey uh can i get some coke zero elo
yeah
just hit me with a little [ __ ]
i think
i could do it with my steady hands
no i'll take elo you sure yeah
what is this
the future dude this is the future
this costs 10
billion dollars
hey uh
ethan you wanted a soda pop
oh there you go
that [ __ ] isn't scary no dude that's a
that's a coke that's a diet coke
right in front of your face
i don't know if that one's really hot
you guys
[Laughter]
yes child pretty cool come here
who knows
let's get the show on the road he's my
favorite ah come on you still have to
perform remember thank you how do we
start this can i just do a set here
hey be respectful yeah listen
again bro
okay
okay so there's a there's an english man
there's a it's like
a scottish man
and and there's an irishman that go into
a pub
they all get a bottle of guinness you
know a big bottle or actually yeah i'm a
guinness goblin respectful anyway
it's just
just when they're about to drink it
three flies
land on each glass
okay so the englishman said
i'm not drinking this i am not drinking
this so he pushes the glass away
the scottish man takes the fly out
throws it
and he drinks it like a man
the irishman looks in his glass he takes
the fly out
and he said it and he says
spit it out you little bastard
uh no
irish people are drunks is that the joke
that is so offensive he just lost make
ethan laughs wow
next this guy for sure paid for applause
own next
all right my phone is next my turn
please thank you you're gonna give us a
set ah it's not yet go sign up
i did i signed up but it's gonna put me
at the back of the boot
you're that bad it's gonna i'm afraid
he's gonna put me in the back of the
line again where is the lion go go go
you've gotta push the button just right
i pushed him
upstage
hey how's everybody doing tonight
thanks for coming out nice to see
everybody
appreciate y'all being here
nice to see you thanks for coming
all right hey
hey you guys hear the one about the uh
that's me now it is me
who said that
shut the [ __ ]
here lively audience thanks for coming
out everybody everyone feeling good can
i get a whoo
all right all right
good good everyone feeling good
feeling good they're trying to kick you
they're trying to kick you why who do
that no no where's the joke you guys
heard the one about hold on damn you
wanna go heck like come on bro
you don't wanna you wanna see me floss
or what oh yeah
oh
man who are you
no i'd like to see you do better
hey did you guys hear the one you're
losing did i hear which one did you guys
hear the one
about the priest
and the kid
the kid went to go see the priest
and the priest raped him
oh no
whoa
get off the stage
no
no good
all right let me try again did you guys
hear the one
about the jew and the muslim that went
to a bar together
yeah doesn't mean you even
i was going to say they had a really
good time but the the muslim guy he
couldn't drink so he had a so he had a
cherry coke
yep
you're telling everyone to pick me up
fight
christie wake up
all right
all right hey did you meet that kid
everybody
so did you all hear the one about the uh
did y'all hear the one you know what
happens
hey you guys ever you guys ever walk a
dog come on come on you got this let's
go run hey you guys ever walk a dog
right
you're walking him right
you guys are having a good time you're
walking
and then the dog takes a [ __ ] you're
like oh man you pick up the [ __ ] right
there's a little bit left it's hard to
pick all this
oh my god i got on my side you've been
booted off i was just getting it that
was your three minutes you're just
getting a good part too what a netflix
special what a set right
yeah i got a joke for you
i got a joke for you
come on outside so i don't get mauled
where are you hey man well i think it
was the cowboy earlier all right i gotta
go guys
all right
this is just out of control all right
let's maybe do one more room yeah yeah
let's do
oh okay so i gotta do this yep you hit
that and
welcome to the future everybody yes
so futuristic then what
uh i don't know why it's not showing the
room yeah
that's what i'm the great
this is a great use this device is going
to be like looked forever after the
stream
well that's what i'm saying why is it
gonna go get banned oh world's there
it's the little yeah
you know what i'm saying
yeah [ __ ] yeah
let's see for you yeah okay
this guy's trying to mess up my screen
though it's not cool he knows
oh you want to do the night club let's
do the party house please don't follow
me guys
stop stream stipping me in meta
i deserve privacy like everybody else
here we go we're loading up
so this is like a dance disco
spot yeah
yeah so
this is mark zuckerberg's 10 billion
dollar beta
or or meta it has four rooms
with a max of 15 people honestly our
waiting screen is way better and then
everything i've seen
thank you this waiting screen in the
background of you
because they don't show your stream
right now yeah their screen sucks dude
only people can hear you okay whatever
all right so
kill the music we're in
all right guys we are here we are ready
to party
party oh this is dope party house get
away from the music
music oh the party
party
it said 18 plus so that's good see if
you can find some meta coke to blow
yeah so
that's six year old go down the medical
here i know it goes down
what cam see if you can find some medico
yeah try and get some k oh
drugs yeah that's a good idea actually
it's like one of those parties
you know where i can get some coke
around here from blow
you guys know where i can get some blow
is it pointing
there uh i think he's mike's muted
they're they're muted you could see the
little symbol why they hear muted weird
yo yo hey
there's a lot of music here yeah
yeah music music yeah mute it yeah
damn that's too bad here we can go score
drugs in another room
i like that idea
let's see top 100 let's see let's see
oh no they have more rooms yeah yeah
there's there's a bunch a flocka
talk about walker
what else you got in there abe
yeah
get it all out of your system
captain
island [ __ ]
keep the change you filthy [ __ ]
let me tell you about [ __ ]
this
[ __ ]
you can't handle the [ __ ] welcome to the
flocka verse
weasley
[Laughter]
all right i'm going to open the audio
back up as soon as you get in remember
train safety specialists may remotely
observe and record your environment what
oh they're always watching
can be temporarily banned what
all right this is the last one all right
i like bringing up your audio my
favorite is talking to the mods and just
yeah well you can always go back to the
community center if this one isn't good
all right this is camp
so
let's see there's a campfire oh it's a
campfire party let's make some friends
i'm scared i don't want to talk hey guys
what are we doing
hey guys everyone have a good time
you guys having a good time in the meta
oh cool awesome where's your
your okay let's not even go there yeah
i'm not a baby
she's about to ask where are your
parents but it's a kid man
just
is there any adults here
should kids be in meta i'm not sure i
like that idea at all i think i hear
music i don't know
uh
yeah there's a stage here we gotta we
gotta get away from that
it's pretty interesting what do you
think about kids being in meta
net well i think it's only 13 and up to
uh
to have an account on facebook right so
hey ethan i'm an adult i'm an adult
ethan
i think you're being streamed tonight
big fan bro don't stream cite me
all right let's play um
what do you call this
cornhole yeah let's play some corn hole
and hey
what
just
this song is going to get us playing
with
i don't think you should stay here all
right we gotta go ah so all right let's
go get banned let's just go out with the
bank oh boy yeah go to the welcome
center again yeah that's where it all is
happening to be honest
everything else is just kind of
mid
hello
alfredo can i get some more sodium how
did you know that was alfredo i can tell
i can tell the difference between all of
them dude
they each have little habits that's
alfredo
i would call that a flocka
very good
i didn't get to play my head earlier
literally lying still lying to his
audience can someone at least [ __ ]
enlighten ethan klein that he's
literally talking to his audience what a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] dude all right
what should i do that's not like too
offensive
dude
all right
all right you're you're back in all
right let me uh let me open this oh i
know what i got banned for last time
okay let's try this again oh boy
hey matthew
what's up buddy you good
yeah okay
vape
con where you live
come on
mysterious america okay cool yeah me too
what's like was that like california
area
i just stole it behind me i don't share
anything specific other than that okay
hey what are you doing okay let's play
are there do you have redwoods around in
your area where you live
what's a redwood
it's a tree it's a bit so much about
trees
bro you shooting
tell me where you live bro
[Laughter]
yeah just tell me where you live why are
you being such a proof behalf of this
category tell me the zip code bro
give me your zip
how do you shoot with the orange that's
for sharing that
point in his face tell me your ip
address
what the [ __ ]
no sorry all right you're all right
thanks mod have fun
hey i recognize you ah they're coming
you've been doing good pass broken paths
[Laughter]
so you said pacific northwest is that
like washington
oregon
good luck ethan
where's facebook offices it's in uh
norcal right
silicon
you work there
dude i can't do this
you working there on facebook you can
find all the
you can find all of the offices online
at metacareers.com are you at one of
them
yeah i don't really like it i'm in an
office okay all right cool
so anyway
how's the weather asking me if you can
get a message to suck uh very sunny hey
hard way come here bro no like in no
like in sun is setting or rising
no like india where the office where you
were tell me the exact temperature i can
figure out where it is stab his ass
i've got air conditioning no but outside
just type google just go on google and
type weather on the barometer tell me
what it says the humidity
[Laughter]
okay all right
yeah so so
do me a favor if you go in the outside
and look at the sun what angle is it
coming down at you we can figure it out
from that
what's the angle of the sun
just tell me if you just look at the sky
and say like oh it's about like 30
degrees we can work with that
the ver
the virtual sus is perfectly fine no no
not that one that's your address it's
kind of weird
okay all right
let me ask you this draco what's the
weirdest thing you've seen on the job
besides me
weirdest thing that i've seen oh
no
where what
the baby
get it bro
where are you here baby puking are you
furry donkey
i think he stopped oh oh
look at this yeah so what color is if
you go outside what color is the soil
what color is the soil
in general in your area there we go
what's the what's the nitrate content
wow the soil i don't know
oh my god
yeah what's your zip code
okay can you just give me the first two
digits
yeah
that was a canadian story what the [ __ ]
bro
what are you pacific northwest are we
talking like
is that uh uh uh
he's in vancouver vancouver
oh you're michael uh
what happened no he's from alaska we're
getting interference for some reason yo
all right
hey you you you canadian cold-blooded
from all the way over here your baby is
just not giving up can i get your email
address from the front right over here
no no
and i agree how can we stay in touch
i work here i i'm usually in a lobby i'm
in a plaza okay all right
jack's calling so you're is do you have
an ad facebook email
you have that facebook email our meta
bro he works at meta on facebook yeah at
meta network
why did you guys all change your email
when that happened i mean there must
have been millions of facebook emails
what happened how does that work
[Laughter]
excuse me
we're having a conversation
a question for you don't be rude can i
not talk to the guy too
go over there
until we're done
shame on you
as i was saying so
facebook or meta email
i'm not gonna disclose any information
about our internal processes
you found the most patient mod of all
time i don't think you're getting banned
should i go further
it's time stay still
this
this is what they've been working
towards they put these force fields in
after that article came out so you can't
even meta sorry this is what you wanted
oh he's doing something oh
i'm so nervous
you just got banned
good job
wow well done it was going too long i
didn't i had to get out of here man
a guide removed you you can remove
august 20 or you can come back august
it's a two-hour suspension not too bad
that's not bad for sexually assaulting
someone
yeah that's pretty good compared to in
real life that's really good in meta
wait
maybe we
like a future segment could be like a
getting banned speedrun oh
well that's essentially what this was
no i mean like go hard right
dude i could get banned literally in
five seconds
like all you gotta do is grab their
crotch
yeah you could take it off i just muted
it oh my god i'm sweating
wow was i i don't know how to like
i just try to be provocative i don't
know if it's funny
because i'm being rude right so i don't
know if it's like funny or just mean
uh i thought it was funny i mean you
weren't yeah i mean you didn't like
insult anybody you were just being
weird asking for their zip code over and
over again i wanted to know where he
lives what's the problem
i think we got close
i think we found the general area no
when we realized canada yeah i think we
got somewhere because he got quiet got
nervous he got quiet he fumbled yeah
sorry not sorry
okay would you guys like that that was
fun everybody's great everybody's
clapping and then in the chat
you guys like this so what maybe it
could be a recurring segment
i will say about meta the technology is
insane
because
it's
wireless you mean the the headset the
headphones that is wireless their own
headset yeah yeah i bought the oculus a
while ago oh because only every time
i've done vr it had these massive bulky
wires you remember when i used to do
those yeah the vibe the vive is fun but
it has these huge so this is really
freeing and not to step over wires and
stuff and no no uh scanners it doesn't
need the scanner
oh yeah you had to install that yeah
like
it didn't make any sense does it without
it and the price points a lot relatively
lower too because the vibe is like a
thousand bucks and this is 400 or so
yeah
that's a good deal like the tech is good
the meta space itself
i don't get but as a business model it
makes no sense to me no wonder they're
charging two dollars for some applause
they gotta recap somehow i can't imagine
people wanting to stand up for a long
time like
how do you compare that to like video
gaming in your own comfort on a couch or
true in bed you can't sit
but that's my problem with it too is
that
for me it's too immersive because when
i'm relaxing and playing video games
or something i'm usually hanging out
with ela there's something else going on
i want to be aware of my surroundings
yeah
so to me it's like two
yeah it's just like two uh
but cam you use it you don't have a
problem with that i guess i mean i
bought it during the first lockdown
because i was like you know socially
isolated at the time and i loved it and
i i don't like to sit down too long
anyway so i like the active element to
it
yeah that is i mean it's nice but i
don't know man i just don't get it what
are the what are they planning on what
are they hoping for
uh i mean there's there's a variety of
games that game sucked that you're just
playing uh i wouldn't play that but i
don't know there's a lot of stuff
there's like shooters and stuff
but it seems like a fun side project why
rebrand your whole company right
they're very forward thinking i guess
but there you go the zok ladies and
gentlemen
i will say a lot of games right now just
feel more like app games in a vr space
than like full
immersive video games at this time too
but i see the potential is there and
it's
going fast i don't know it's advancing
fast so maybe 10 years from now it'll be
fully like ready player one
my favorite part was seeing like an old
looking dude with like pierced things
and a full beard and then it's a kid and
i got a meal i gotta have a run that was
really my favorite part it's a holy [ __ ]
it was like eight it felt like club
penguin did you ever play that no i did
it essentially that just you couldn't
talk you would type
yeah holy smokes man
i was playing basketball in it before
the show was pretty fun a bunch of kids
were making fun of me but it was it was
fun like real life
yeah pretty much i suck at basketball
all right well let's move on to the ta
to uh tate speech
let's just enjoy this moment
we're not going to be able to dunk on
andrew
anymore
this is our bon voyage
voyage our fond farewell to a friend
i have a question so we're okay to show
if we're talking about him
show him
like
because he's banned you're willing
like him on tucker you can show that i
think
it has to be i mean we've been talking
about them all week okay i mean that'd
be kind of nuts if because like we've
shown alex jones clips and no right well
that was an accident oh it was an
accident okay what do we do about it
what do we do about it
that's the one time i talked to joe
rogan when i got
alex he immediately dm me he's like yo
what happened
he's like yo what happened they banned
you just for talking about alex you got
off
yeah
the h3 podcast
yes so anyway
uh let's enjoy this moment okay
so andrew taint
now banned from youtube tick tock
twitter instagram and facebook and
apparently his processors too this man
he challenged the world
to cancel him
and the world responded be careful what
you wish for cancel me i do not care i
don't care
he seems to care now he posted
on vimeo again which is awesome
why is he why does he look like he's on
the star trek enterprise
are you doing here
so he's got clothes now okay
[Laughter]
andrew tate's final message and what's
interesting is he had the bidding of
these social media influencers i don't
know how he got
convinced these idiots to share this
adam ross of course his little his
little uh dick rider
what's his name again olivia [ __ ]
the gaston's little henchman lefou
[Music]
damn right i don't give a [ __ ] little
waffle oh andrew i pity lefou
you're a dick rider you're a dick sucker
hop off my [ __ ] dick
of course aiden is the biggest dick
writer of all andrew hit me up and told
me to tell everyone
his last message to the world so andrew
tate's last message
here it is wow how's his dick taste adam
tastes cancelled
he subscribes to the jordan peterson
philosophy of final message by the way
just like jordan peterson
final tweet [ __ ] you
immediately followed up by 20 more
tweets
exactly wait what website is this on
rumble
oh emergency meeting
live right now maybe he is oh he's live
right now people watching so it's pretty
big over there wow
emergency a rumble won't cancel you for
anything man
insane
you could literally like
kill a child on stream and they'd be
like cool free speech
uh the matrix attacks
yeah
the matrix attacks so anyway
it was aiden ross who posted it it was
also jake paul who posted it he did
which is weird because he called him out
right yeah i thought he called him out
i'll tell you why
jake paul is trying to fight him
he's trying to do a big boxing match
with them
and so he has a vested interest in him
keeping up appearance or staying
relevant right i don't think yeah i
think he doesn't like him and he's all
for probably de-platforming him maybe
after they fight and after money
i don't roll with andrew taylor i may
chao his ass out in the ring one day
soon
but i roll with freedom of speech
brother
andrew tate speaks on the band
so brave of them man
literally
i mean
they're so brave i'm just so brave
they're all big boys i just love that
everybody goes to battle
in this case
yeah it's ridic the people who chose not
to even speak about what he was saying
in the first place are like riding hard
for free speech yeah dude and i have to
say i've been saying this the whole time
but it's so true i have not seen a
single woman defending him yeah
i haven't it's all men
even if you do i i'm not gonna care that
much you know you can always find
somebody saying something but
i haven't seen even one it's because for
all men this is a hypothetical like
getting targeted hate
by like what they're spewing it's all
like doesn't exist it doesn't exist for
them it's it's what if i were a woman
and i were and i were feeling this and
then they refused to actually be
empathetic men don't
women have a lot to deal with by the way
here's my favorite here's adam ross and
please send this to him i mean if you're
i think it's important that people see
this right
um
i feel like they're all
missing the point and this is the year
that we
currently lost like
freedom of our own body here in america
yeah
so
clearly things are a little bit more
than just like ideas and thoughts dude
that's you know climbing of it too we
can't get abortion like what are you
talking about it's my body and i don't
have freedom on my own body right now
like i do personally here in l.a but i
don't know
you know
i feel like if you're willing to go to
bat for him and for free speech you're
at least a little bit okay
with what he's saying that's what i
think because
if it's so
wrong
and it's which it clearly is
you would be fine with nobody absorbing
that information because you'd be like
nobody needs to hear that because it's
not real you know how i know you're
right nobody cried when isis you for
real got banned i didn't hear anyone
crying free speech then it's like
it's like this is an opinion that that
women suck that's an opinion yeah
it's a lot worse than women suck right
well you're saying that's an opinion
right i'm saying that they they are they
are saying the the
the all-encompassing women are worse
that's just my opinion that's what i
think but it's just factually like you
can't prove that it's wrong
and also from personal experience it's
wrong
i don't think there's anything wrong
with being like oh i think women it's
it's everything this man is a [ __ ]
menace it's a hake a violent hate group
which i keep saying
but yeah it's in the totality and men
let's be honest if we're honest with
ourselves
we don't deal with the [ __ ] women do
women are scared to go out by themselves
there's a real threat to them of
violence
uh women are scared you know being
scared to go meet someone for the first
time
doing all kinds of stuff being when some
creep guy comes and like dog calls you
and you have to be nice to him because
you're afraid he's gonna kill you i mean
men do not understand this like constant
women have this constant guard up right
it's a whole different experience and
always just getting in an uber by
yourself right driver is male and you're
a female
anything like having a technician come
to your house to fix something and
you're alive right it doesn't matter
it's always there and growing up things
happen to young girls you know like
almost everybody i know in my own life
have a story of something that happened
to them yeah something inappropriate
pretty much everybody like seriously
it's insane so
i just i don't know i i feel like kind
of like olivia said like in a way
everybody that's fighting for this
they're either like major sellout or
they kind of agree with what he's saying
i think you're i think you're right on
they agree they agree with this to an
extent at least to an extent yeah
because again
i would like to know when isis got
banned around the time the apocalypse
had they got there was a big problem
right
isis was monetizing its youtube channel
and that was a big part of what caused
the adpocalypse they were get they were
having like you know
bounty [ __ ]
paperwhite paper towels on isis videos
that was a problem dude nobody
complained when they got shut down
freedom of speech
technically applies to isis as much as
anyone right i must say that legally
speaking
regrets about that phrase but nobody
gives a [ __ ] yeah it's a it's a
almost sickening lack of empathy even of
the smallest
amount from these men
who are so proud to pronounce their
protection of his right to to spew hate
against women also we are seeing that it
is already affecting kids right from
these teachers that are speaking out
yeah so why are we worrying about some
hypothetical of like what if when
uh the tech billionaires are not gonna
let freedom of speech do whatever i
don't know like they're so caught up on
some hypothetical it's like let's talk
about reality do you want kids in your
own country to learn this stuff
is this the reality we all want like
this is gonna affect
everybody yeah totally and you know
again that's kind of what was happening
when i was talking with tim no offense
to tim again we had a great conversation
and i love him as a guy
but he kept going back to like a big
hypothetical
uh threat
of
corporate censorship of like who gets to
decide
my thing is like
i don't really that's not a problem now
and by the way these are two separate
issues right like you can you can
separate these issues
twitter needs some oversight right maybe
i don't even know how that works you
would have to nationalize twitter which
he didn't want to admit to either it
doesn't make any sense but you can say
oh well we need some oversight
and also andrew tate is a hate he's a
violent hate speech
and he needs to be uh removed
you know
but at any rate it is pretty interesting
and it's like man people have worked so
hard to bring awareness to stuff like
you've been through me too and then even
in the wake of like the repeal of roe
yeah
there's still these [ __ ] people are
still riding for him it's insane this is
crazy man
the world has enough men who hurt
women i don't think we should be making
more yeah
well uh jake paul agrees flocka agrees
blocker agrees though can i get a flocka
yeah flocka yeah
all right let's
go so this guy put out an hour long
video of him crying i don't know
hour long yeah let's see what's the tone
of his like
wait don't we don't we have a
an edit of it i guess you could you
could just see
thank god yeah i was thinking for a long
time how to start this video
because it needs to be concise two
camera baby
you're already lost concise it's over an
hour you already lost me
if it needs to be concise don't talk
about how it needs to be concise oh
that's true be concise edit it down
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh
loser you're gonna pound me you're gonna
keep me hanging oh yeah
thanks
and compendious
but i also want it to be very very
comprehensive
and i guess the best place to start is
at the beginning
uh there's been many bro get it started
the beginning
what is the beginning jordan peterson
was there and what is what what are
beginnings what even does it mean to
start
[ __ ] you
who cares what you believe what matters
matters
matter man better than that interesting
definition a little bit weird
but that's just it isn't it matter is
what matters
phd
ground shaking [ __ ] revelations
of my life
yeah you're gonna start crying
with that thought too all right
you're the worst shut the [ __ ] up
babies
thank you cam
internet as of late and from many years
ago
but i'm going to give a very very quick
overview of my story
your story oh my god hell no all right
let's go to the mega cup come to join us
and together we'll end women
wow
wait what at least they said it
that was the maestro zach that was not
okay
that's a big
that's a big investment there yeah
i don't know i don't think i've ever
heard zach play it i hope i didn't
really he has some good ones that like
he keeps thank you for the perfect
moment
um
but yeah i hope i didn't ruin that zach
did he [ __ ] that up i think he's in chat
isn't he
he's acting yeah he's drawing
sipping drinks on the beach right now
all right well here is allegedly
what's the zip
what does at mean
it really depends what the definition of
definition is
so here is uh the reader's digest
version
i guess it's not even necessarily a
super cut is uh there are some parts
that are relevant to us that uh i was
thinking for all right well three
minutes that's about all i can stomach
this
a long time how to start this video hey
let me turn the quality up
oh that's all we get okay
because it needs to be concise
and compenduous he slapped me in the
face from behind and busted his eye
clean open the plastic batman lunchbox
the boss had just come up to wait hold
on it needs to be said that he put in
that sound effect he did yep
what
you didn't know that
he has like goofy yeah little sound drop
it's a whole radio play but radio play
video ethan
yeah no including the sound effects
that's a real drop
that's not us
what the i'm busting his eye
plastic batman
dude i'll pull up the source do you know
the i'll show you guys so you believe me
no i believe it it's just why why are
you doing that
because he's a episode of radio lab
exactly that's what it is
yeah
they literally played him walking he
mentioned yeah so i was walking and
there's like footsteps oh my god god are
you kidding me i don't really know wow
more sincere makes it that just makes it
feel weird yeah the the footsteps in the
edit wow
the bus had just come up to a stop it
was a few stops performing the bus door
i heard it and that's the bus that's the
sound effect yes oh my god oh my god
yo wow i feel like i'm really on the bus
right now yeah i know this guy's got to
like get into movies or something not
his editor the audio guy good
he's passionate it was a few stops
and as the bus stopped and the screaming
happened i just got up and i ran and i
just ran off the bus ran ran ran ran ran
where's the part where you get into
human trafficking
why is he running
he's like telling his whole child story
i mean what the [ __ ] from
when i got home
i had blood on my clothes my dad looked
at me i actually had a friend in school
who was are you serious
that one was me
that was the first one i did just for
the record
hold on now nobody's gonna believe it
no i just clarified
that's the sound of the beast
i go to church anyone who follows me
in detail knows i donate huge sums of
money to the church sitting there
believing that depression is some
monster from the sky that strikes your
brain and now you have no control over
and you must take pills every day if god
believes that i do not need an instagram
page then i will not have one
if god believes i do then i shall
god i think it's safe to assume he
doesn't want you on social media yeah
god has spoken my dude crazy quote i'm
just saying
god has spoken you literally lost
everything in the course of like three
days if that's not an act of god i don't
know what is
the [ __ ] is this finally an ice cream
named after me oh magnum why because he
has a big dick
is that the joke tree that i wrote if my
mentality is so wrong how have i managed
to amass enormous wealth how have i
managed to physically dominate uh crime
no bad person has ever gotten rich in
the history of the world you get rich
righteous literally crime stopped money
yeah crime
nope no no you're both wrong
he's right if you are rich you must be
great inside you found god well if you
ask billionaires they definitely would
like that uh conclusion enormous wealth
how am i managed to physically dominate
the planet i've done things that men
respect you're not hold on where is your
enormous uh wealth
right now
how much is that are you still finding
it yeah he makes these because maybe
that kind of shows the opposite
his massive statements like i have
dominated the planet yeah he just got
banned off every social media in three
days yeah clearly notice you're saying
it all in past right dominated you know
what i think we need to do
i think a woman needs to put him on a
webcam and lock him in a dungeon and
take the revenue
i think that's how we redeem him
i we're raising him i think we would we
should do that but make him think that
it's live but don't actually broadcast
it anymore
but he actually cut in all these dick
writing comments of his paying fans to
prove that he's a great guy i'm a woman
but your videos and speeches help me
fight my depression
wow andrew tate saved my life
he did that yeah he put these in oh my
god
these brothers single-handedly caring is
how to be a good man in all aspects
yo people said that about you on youtube
why don't you read the negative ones too
also there's those are definitely real
right
every time a comment starts with i'm a
woman for sure
that is
nobody would ever lie on this i i always
start when i comment by saying i'm a man
[Laughter]
have i managed to physically dominate
the planet i've done things that men
respect we're raising important issues
in the world today because of me
deleting me and blocking me is only
going to hurt men as a whole strength
isn't good really i love that anything
we do to andrew is is a
attack on all men everywhere all of them
four billion people on the planet
we're all suffering if you hate andrew
tape you hate men
olivia yeah
how does that feel
dudes rule girls drool yeah
i think tate is a separate
beast olivia and that's
a piece of [ __ ]
so
uh well there you have it such a little
[ __ ]
it's the beautiful thing the world is
built on the backs of strong men and i'm
trying to teach men what would we do
to be fair with that i i don't think
women had much of a [ __ ] uh option to
contribute much
it's like it's like you don't allow them
to participate through the whole course
of history up until like the last 50
years and it's like men built this world
bow before us kiss my feet
it's like yeah dude
[ __ ] women were like dying in
childbirth and being forced to like
stay in the house and not
do anything so you know given the option
probably be a lot more women
participating in your incredible
society that you built somehow
one thing
you taking credit for all that
strong again because it makes the men
feel happier inside it solves men's
mental health and it also makes the
world a genuinely better place
please if you want to have more
information you can go to cobertdate.com
sign up to the emailing list and my
emailing list is going to start
detailing all of my charitable acts yeah
so when aaron ross or jake paul or
whoever
i mean
you're promoting him what are you doing
he's just he's just shielding his [ __ ]
again
morons
everyone that tweeted this is a [ __ ]
idiot
total idiot it's actually even worse
than that they're like malignant [ __ ]
idiots dude they're like
self-reported
losers bro
find one woman that tweeted this [ __ ]
another women hating sheep
i know i've only seen men tweet this
like period exactly what does that mean
what does that mean
holy [ __ ]
more information you can go to
cobratape.com sign up to the emailing
list and my emailing list is going to
start detailing all of my charitable
acts from here on out i just really oh
man that's dope he's going to have a
list of all his charitable blocks
that's normal
yeah that's cool man that's normal i
like to do that too i have a big old
list on my
on my wall
that we update every time
uh i do something nice for anybody right
because it's so little it can fit in a
little list no it's massive how dare you
i'm talking about him
uh
yeah
yeah i know i know
yeah let's just keep watching
i said guys listen what i said is what i
said okay
trust me
there's no exception
there's no exceptions
recently rebuilt an entire orphanage
because there's an orphanage problem
with romania i did this
orphan shut up
the tate foundation that's probably just
a funnel for sex trafficking
sounds like something the fbi should
look into yeah for real this man has an
orphanage okay can we
please alert the authorities you can be
nervous
holy [ __ ]
months ago before anybody disliked me i
find it very hypocritical when these
hate mobs come and say i'm a bad person
when i'm the one who's out here spending
his money and time
trying to help the world i shut the [ __ ]
up
oh my god you run a pyramid scheme dude
what the [ __ ] are you talking about well
that's what i that's why it's so
annoying that people share this because
it's just like straight propaganda
it's literally art it's just straight
propaganda and then shilling to his new
program even if you just ignore the fact
that he's a giant misogynist and piece
of [ __ ] just ignore that just on the
basis of what you do you run a you run a
cam girl website and a ponzi scheme how
the [ __ ] are you helping the world like
what are you smoking dude
well yeah that's a car i mean listen
this is the strategy that's employed by
horrible people
throughout the course of society they're
rich they use a minuscule fraction of
their hoarded wealth to do nice things
just to win i mean look at like uh pablo
escobar
bill gates i've come around to that
you know
uh there's tons of there's tons of these
families
it's like you build an orphanage and
then everything's good
in life more extreme than most i've been
a multi-millionaire i've been a nobody
i've been uh bro this is over this whole
[ __ ] we're not
we're not doing this right you
he's he's just doing like an ad
right yeah it's like this
this failed bro let's get to the point i
mean
what the [ __ ] here spending his money in
time
trying to help the world i've lived an
extreme life more extreme than most i've
been a multi-millionaire was this
appealing to dude i'm so cool who was
this appealing to i just love that it's
all in past tense like did you die
i've lived in an amazing life yeah
what's this final message to the world
also catch him tonight on the highest
rated cable news show in the united
states right right i've been completely
silenced yeah
yeah
i've been uh famous i'm talking about
the allegations
it's so true
left and people who speak and then
people say oh twitter's the only place
you can talk youtube's the only place
you can talk the man's on rumble or with
a hundred thousand viewers like there is
if there's an opportunity in the market
to host pedophiles and nazis that have
been banned on other platforms they
found a market opportunity
and they're serving it yeah that's the
warning baby
yeah they've got a corner on the nazi
pedophile uh and sex trafficker corner
and that that's god bless him for that
so you have all the speech you need
and
talk about tolerance and inclusivity
will assume that romania as a country
will allow me to be a rapist or that
romania is the kind of place where rape
is okay that's bro
stop it you literally
you said that yeah
you said
literally i live in romania because i
can rape people
basically more or less maybe not
literally
pull up the clip
bro you said this do we have that clip
have you seen it yeah a long time ago in
the beginning yeah we we've played
talking about him i just i think it's
important just to just it was it was
that they have more relaxed laws yeah
and that yeah and he was saying in the
sense of like oh in the west in the west
which romania isn't part of the west yes
[ __ ] european country here this nato
country this is 40 of the reason he
moved to romania
oh and then can you find the clip of him
saying that he pays off the romanian
police too
that they won't touch him because he's
too important or something because in
eastern europe none of this wise if
you're gonna go to the police and say he
raped me back in 1988 so he should have
done something about it then you know
the police say rape yesterday okay if
you've got physical evidence or is there
cctv proof where to happen okay let's go
interview them right now and if it
wasn't really right oh that's oh we went
to the club we got drunk she agreed to
go back to my house we started having
sex and then we carried on having sex
and then we had sex and she didn't say
anything wrong and then she texted me
afterwards and i didn't text back and
now she's saying i raped her the police
was like okay she's an idiot bye yeah
yeah cool he's like i love romania
because basically you can't charge
anyone for rapier
also just in this little clip is
basically saying like if a girl drank
and then had sex there's no way that it
was not coincidental yeah
great great stuff and i just i just love
that
he's doing this so frequently he had to
move
to romania
to hedge his bets of being arrested like
this this is an every week occurrence
for him no not in the west in the west
you can tell them that exact story
you're still [ __ ] you're [ __ ] in the
west people say why didn't romania and i
explained my five reasons one of them is
the metoo era they go oh well you're a
rapist i say no i'm a [ __ ] rapist but
i like the idea of being able to just
say to do what i want i like being free
i'm not a rapist i just like the idea of
being able to do what i want to women
yeah jesus that's disgusting i like
being free
and if you're a man living in england or
germany or america or any of the western
world right now you've decided to live
in a country india is the western world
stop like oh my god
wait what did you what did you say he's
always talking about the west the west
you live in romania yeah that's right
it's an eu country it's in nato it's the
west like
it's funny he always goes you're being
racist against romanians
he's like i live in the third world
romania yeah it's not a third world
country it's like shut the [ __ ] up any
ex any [ __ ]
[ __ ] who works at greg's you walk past
you from at some point in the future can
destroy your life this me too era
[ __ ] has not protected women it's
just destroyed the safety of men all
right so it is so upsetting to listen to
this like i don't know if guys have the
same reaction they don't it's really
upsetting it makes me like it makes my
blood boil just listening to it so let's
take what we heard in consideration and
then go back to him talking about
why he lives in romania people who speak
and
talk about tolerance and inclusivity
will assume that romania as a country
will allow me to be a rapist or that
romania is the kind of place where rape
is okay that's an extremely racist
mentality to have drove my rolls-royce
to ukraine
i find it strange that the left and
people who speak
and
talk about tolerance and inclusivity
will assume that romania sorry sorry
there's trying to help the world i've
lived an extreme life more extreme than
most
and people who speak
and
talk about tolerance and inclusivity
i get i gotta get out is okay that's an
extreme it's really loud here by the way
racist mentality to have drove my rolls
royce to ukraine
i bought hundreds of coats and shoes for
women and children fleeing the car he
included this
yeah correct okay
i look oh he goes i rode my rolls-royce
into ukraine
with like two hundred dollars of clothes
from ross
why'd you have to say you rode rode your
rolls-royce like why's it gonna be about
your wealth when you're trying to help
people
conflict
i didn't film the refugees
i hate when people do that
so we'll be documenting that stay away
from low quality people
if you're struggling to find quality men
to be friends with maybe you're not
quality yo it's rolo tono browntown
and it's rolo tony
rolo tony
check yourself right at the door
i am in better shape
what are you afraid of ian what are you
afraid of ian
i love that these guys are all friends
man isn't that the best
it's like a loser's it's like a [ __ ]
uh kind of losers
it's like a uh
i can't remember my brain is freaking
coconut some barbados yeah it's like
picking coconuts and barbados
it's a support group honestly anyone
that has shared his video people should
reply with the video we just watched
in the replies
that video
if that doesn't make your blood boil
something is wrong with you why are they
just like sending people to go sign up
for his ponzi scheme it's like that's
all you're doing it's crazy bro it's the
worst crazy
damn it's crazy yeah i mean the reason
your marriage is working i'm i inspired
you to send your son to the gym i love
hearing these things
and you can send me an email at the
email address below tate at coverage
thanks that this is if you want to thank
me you can email me at thanks
send your appreciation here for me
please
the conquest is continuing
so this is just the beginning of the
world because a lot of people are saying
like you're going to fall off soon this
is just
what's your take on that that's fine
bro there ain't there's slapped me in
the face from behind
yeah i was thinking
he's he's gonna be gone in like a month
i feel like
like
i live in the same space it is gone but
yeah i live in the same city as rollo
tony and it's so scary no that knowing
that he's here roller coaster and if he
has other friends who are men like him
yeah
don't worry he doesn't leave his studio
he's old and fr and feeble too like
[ __ ] 60.
i am in better shape than you are ethan
[Laughter]
[ __ ] ass
um
yeah the whole video is essentially just
downplaying his harm
to young men saying that he's a
saint
there was a pardon that i saw where he
was talking about this how the human
trafficking charges were is that here
because that was like the best part
oh okay okay
yeah he watched this [ __ ]
he includes a clip of me
he does my house was raided by police
under accusations that a woman was being
held kidnapped wait stop it
that was you ab stop that was his video
i paused it he was trying to set the
scene for the raid
my house people are not going to believe
that he's actually putting these sound
effects in if you keep doing that
that's not me
traded by police under accusations that
a woman was okay i'm done
maybe
i did it once i say it every time who
did it that time
yeah i did that time under accusations
that a woman was being held kidnapped
i have spoke about this at length many
many times
i was effectively swatted i think this
happens to all famous people on the
internet where the police is called it's
happening in america they call the
police and say somebody has got a gun at
this address and he's threatening to
kill somebody and the swap turn up and
it turns out it's fake it happened to
tim paul repeatedly it happened to ayden
ross just the other day being swapped is
unfortunately one of the things that
happens when you're famous in the
internet whatever troll did it you did
it
you officially did it oh we got swatted
yesterday it's so upsetting
just right after my mom arrived
oh that's it yeah just that
included you as a famous person
but yo dude is trying to gaslight people
into thinking he got swatted the man had
a swo he a man had a
tactical team on a tip from the u.s
embassy saying he kidnapped and was
holding women against their will he was
arrested on suspicion of human
trafficking oh that's what he's calling
sliding
and the investigation is still ongoing
me that that's what he's referring to
he's saying oh he just got spotted
that's all
no isn't that crazy baby no
i didn't understand that yeah he's like
no no no i just got swatted you guys
know what that is how do you explain
that
that's a jordan peterson how do you
explain that
yeah is that wow best gas lighting ever
nice reach so bad i was swatted
someone made a call about me which was
fake
the police responded as they should i
would hate another country where so
please
call that woman
and they don't bother going to look
that's not what countries should do
absolutely the romanian authorities were
exceptionally professional i have
nothing but positive things to say about
them they turned up professionally
turned up and investigated as they
should and they found out that it was
completely false that nobody was
kidnapped nobody was held against their
will
i was not charged i was not yeah so it's
an ongoing and they have not closed this
case right dan you have you know about
that
yeah there was like an update earlier
this month like in august that uh
that the case is still open and pending
so
he may end up in jail in the next couple
months who knows let's go yeah i think
he'll go to jail or die
from the mafia right yeah yeah
i mean someone close to him
put out some kind of
video about him they said that he wrote
he wanders money for the mafia
oh
yeah which could also explain
some of his wealth
not released on bail i have no criminal
charges in romania england america any
country on the planet i have no
accusations against me for her if that's
true then fly to america right now and
see what happens
this man cannot get off of a terminal
guarantee you
marrying women and people are still
knitting us saying he's a human
trafficker the romanian police are
trying to get in trouble for human
trafficking that's not true that's not
what happened and i've said this many
times but people continue to ignore it
and continue to report the lie because
that's how the internet works i can't
believe he got alive because it gets
more clicks or because they personally
don't like me and they want to use it as
an excuse to pretend i'm a bad person
i can sit here and be vain i would never
that is the dumbest thing i've ever bro
i would never lie it was just a swatting
anyway join my program to get rich fast
fast and easy i would never lie to you
so trump didn't get raided by the fbi he
got swatted it was a prank
that's a good point it was just a prank
someone caught made a call someone
called and said that there's fake
documents and you know
he got swatted that would be actually a
really interesting defense for him i was
swatted
somebody pranked the fbi it was a swat
they came they saw i was doing nothing
wrong
wow he likes me i was doing nothing
wrong they apologized they laughed
good people good people at the fbi
and arrogant to say they're jealous of
me and my success and they want to find
a way to drag me down but that's beside
the point the actual point is it's not
true and i was swatted just like anyone
else was and if i hadn't actually heard
anybody the romanian police would have
me in jail
because they are a nation a european
union nation with a strong legal system
and they would lock me up they have not
done that because i am completely and
utterly innocent they investigated as
they should and came to the correct
conclusion that there's nobody here and
this was a false call a false alarm it
happens to lots of famous people happens
all the time
i've never seen that happen what
happened to him ever
you know
never
yeah do we have any intel on if the case
is open or
what's the status on that investigation
i'm still looking right now i think
dan's looking as well
uh i'm not again i just saw that it
reported
was that you or soundbite that was me oh
okay
i just saw that it was reported a couple
weeks ago that uh
somebody reached out to interpol or
whatever and they said there's an
ongoing investigation so somebody said
the uh
bytes are allowed i don't know if that's
just read that in the chat audio audio
audio
the person who made the call about me
threw in instead of saying i kind of
think
if i analyze it
the people who make these police calls
right the people who do the swatting
it's kind of country specific in america
they make a call to the police and they
say he has a gun he has hostages they
can't really say that in romania because
it's very very unlikely it's not likely
to be taken seriously so instead they
try and find something the police might
believe oh he's an american guy and he
has this big house he has a bunch of
women trapped
it's a different story but
i love that that's believable here yeah
we we see that all the time from tate
apparently when that happened he
appeared to address the raid in an
instagram picture featuring him smoking
a cigar in a staged interrogation room
as a faux police officer loomed over him
and tape tate added a caption saying
officer i think we can all agree that
[ __ ] love to lie
[Music]
yes
slay
yeah there was a clip of him saying he
he pays off the romanian police but i
think it was erased with his youtube
channel
from what i can tell
same intention for the police to turn up
with guns and thankfully thank god
nobody was shot nobody was hurt they
were very professional very calm as was
i very calm conversations very kind
everything was sorted out very quickly
i was taken from my house
they came into my house at 5 pm they did
a forensic search as they should
uh at 8 pm the search concluded they
took me from my house at 8 pm for
paperwork at the police station and by 9
21 i was back home and that was the end
of it nothing's happened since no
woman's come forward nobody's hurt
nothing
so right away that's completely
flighting is like something that happens
here in america
there's very little it wasn't
it's ridiculous to even say that
such a gaslighting thing it's insane
yeah and then tate went on tucker
carlson do we was that ever turn into
anything interesting
he was on last night i mean we've seen
the preview
did anyone watch him on tucker
yeah it's just usually the same spiel
it's just the same yeah the same old the
same old song and dance
uh
yeah
this was one funny observation you
remember how they were getting tons of
comments saying
uh
everywhere yeah and this person had a
really funny
interpretation they said oh my god this
is gold
tate told his taunts
go to h3 and write top g
everywhere
but because they're literally kids
they thought he meant top g everywhere
because it that don't work that makes so
much sense
everywhere
oh my god that's so funny such a good
catch
all right so that's it there you go
that's it
we're closing the book all right andrew
tate
smell you later
here i just uh
found an article let's see when was this
written this is from august 6
that's only 20 days ago uh romanian
authorities said last week so that would
have been the very end of july
that the
investigation is ongoing as a later
expanded to cover human trafficking and
rape allegations
wow
that is not that sounds pretty serious i
heard an investigation so that sounds
into a lot more than oh they found it to
be nothing that's
no i heard they just swatted him yeah he
was just swatted he was just wanted it
was all they must have been used
the romanian authorities
when they said that
all right what else we got i don't i
don't really want to talk about gabby
hannah
gabby hannah's situation is just sad
honestly and concerning and
worrying for her
yeah she's having like
i don't want to diagnose her but it
seems to me
my best guess is some kind of manic
episode probably
some kind of bipolar if i had to guess
but again i'm not i don't want to even
diagnose her let's just say she's having
some kind of manic
situation where she's just like
posting on tick tock a lot a lot like
non-stop she has said in the past like a
year ago she said that she was diagnosed
with bipolar um but she also has talked
about how her diagnoses are ongoing so
i've known people with bipolar that's
kind of what i
thought it was because when you get into
a manic
state when you're bipolar
you can you become really like delusion
delusions of grandeur psychosis you get
really detached
and anyway i just i don't really want to
go into all of it because it just
reminds me of
this has happened before we've seen this
happen before
we've lost people on youtube
from people like
when they're when when these people are
in a manic state they're they're
detached from reality
so gabby's saying stuff on tick tock and
then people are going on twitter and
writing essays about how
she's racist and how she's a piece of
[ __ ] and all this
and that that just kind of shocks me
because she's obviously not in her right
mind and i don't she definitely doesn't
need ridicule right now that's happened
before and this and we've lost these
people
because when you when you come down from
the manic you go to the depressive and
it can hit hard
and people can on the lives of
themselves it actually happens
more frequently with bipolar people than
than not
and so like
you know
like i said everyone says not again and
then they still ridiculing her
still doing the same [ __ ] that happened
before
i think i'm just not i don't want to
talk about the whole thing that much
because i think the last thing she needs
is just
more attention and more fuel
i think she's probably off her medicine
and hopefully she can you know
stabilize
then everyone can you know explain i
don't know whatever
but
obviously there's a lot here
this actually this is interesting a lot
of people were wondering like why isn't
anybody
attending to her yeah
gabby's sister
left a comment
on gabby's post she said this video was
filmed and posted a full day before
anything was happening
or at least before we were aware we're
all in pennsylvania and she's in la we
are doing what we can do from here at
the end of the day
you're all strangers on the internet and
it's none of your business regardless of
level of concern obviously we are aware
and doing what we can she's an adult i
am 20 year old on the other side of the
country
it's hard like i don't
i don't want to even dude it's
impossible speculate it's it's for every
family that has to deal with something
like that it's so hard on all the family
yeah and everyone involved so
yeah dude it's
it's impossible to
wrangle someone in a manic episode like
that because
they are and they're not going to comply
at all
right they're not going to listen to
reason at all yeah
they're gonna
see what you're doing as like in a
paranoid state as like
an attack
right
so it's not always the best uh it's
tricky anyway just wish the best and
hope that people are being uh
considerate
of the situation and not
making it worse for her
there it is
there we have it
that is
i think that's it
well it is
about this specific topic or just in
general just in general in general
there's a really cool slide in detroit i
think you'd like to watch that
is that at the bottom yeah
metal slide in detroit closed yeah a few
hours after it opened yeah so this slide
has been around since the 60s they
closed it because it coveted and they
reopened it and they had to immediately
reclose it
if you guys ever wonder why i'm [ __ ]
up just look at the slides
this is what we have to go through it
just doesn't seem like that advanced
physics to get that right
it looks fun kind of well here it is
thankful yeah
let's see yeah
this is what i thought it would be
for real
[Applause]
oh my god oh my gosh we would go on that
after watching that who made that why
did they make it
i wonder if that was the first ride
it was the maiden voyage
why did anyone think to make this so
this is the clip that's been going viral
but it doesn't do it justice i included
a drone shot so you can see just how big
it is it doesn't look as big from this
angle oh that's so funny here's the
drone angle
shout out to oh yeah it's a lot bigger
oh
my god
is she whacking her head
like
she's doing fine i feel like you need a
helmet it's a girl
the brunt of the hit every single time
dude she definitely got a concussion
people are still walking up
funny enough if you're from detroit you
know this slide is the least dangerous
thing happening
it's the best safest way to spend your
weekend
it's like rusty and [ __ ] there too oh my
god it's history baby
why is it also in the middle of like
nothing else
like no other rights what is this this
is like a little island type area here
we go lena how do you describe belle
island i know how to describe it
it goes bad on that second one
is that part of the fun that you just
get [ __ ] up because you have to keep
it kinda yeah i imagine
why how is that fun so get this they
closed it and they said they found a
solution is to water the slide in
between put some water in between
people are gonna fly off that
[ __ ]
this is like that uh
what i don't know what country was it
and where they do they all run downhill
with the flight
[Laughter]
here we go good luck guys
oh no
that looks so
damaged like to your spine
i survived look how many people are
there
man that could be i would like to go
there and watch yeah
yeah
i'm so mad i didn't go there while i was
there this guy could go around after
i'd love to see your ass go down that oh
next time i'm there oh [ __ ] could be
winner next time i'm there
next summer bring a sled man this place
is a hoop
so they closed it because it's too
dangerous it seems like people are
enjoying it yeah i'm gonna break their
neck or something i don't think so i
just think it's just going too fast but
i'm just curious it's making it go so
fast now because it's been open for like
40 years so
i don't know
what do we do about it
what do we do about it glide i want
power
i need more footage of this slide
yeah let's go back to this one i want to
see that oh wait they have something
similar in sweden
love says this is the standard issue
slide in sweden why yeah
yeah it's like the
default standard slide they have these
every slide with bumps
it doesn't make sense
what is the idea of the bump and like i
don't know if you go down this you also
eat [ __ ]
okay yeah every time
but
this this is insane but
look at the texture though the texture
is smooth on this yeah the right one is
broken like see it's all like these
little corrugated yards of metal
sticking out
let's watch this again i love watching
this
is it kind of like the like an escalator
material
exactly yes i was trying to figure out
how to describe it
that's like a nightmare yeah that's
painful i feel like that's it's a
nightmare it's probably made of like
aluminum that's what the little beanies
for
the little beanie bag
dude this girl literally may have died
look at this poor woman
lift your head up no
girl she didn't learn
oh no you can see also if you look
closely oh they have it in germany too
why
look at her wait you guys gotta watch
her
reaction okay the girl in pink
she just doubled over in pain
she's done
dude i want more videos of this oh get
this it reopens today
we should go
wow
congratulations
congratulations
that girl got so [ __ ]
i also feel like this the walls on the
side aren't high enough to keep somebody
from flying off that's true they're
getting higher than the walls in mexico
too are you guys kidding now or is it
really everywhere no i wouldn't be
surprised but wait yes i mean i've seen
slides with
i mean i've done slides like that there
was one at ace fest like but not this
big
it's something about the way that
particular one is designed it seems like
that
yeah we don't have wine it's not big
like yeah maybe it's like a standard
issue
i'm more interested in people being like
severely hurt going down the slide like
it's so big does that happen in mexico i
mean this seems unique
seems like a unique experience to get
injured
this is great man
i could watch
canada too
oh [ __ ] we need to send uh my cousin tim
down that slide oh okay i'd like to find
it actually everybody's asking about the
giant slide wrap maybe they played for
us earlier yeah i it's in the dock i
re-uploaded it didn't get claimed so
there's a detroit rapper uh who made a
song about it it's pretty funny wait
this slide is so legendary that that it
didn't get claimed no i i uploaded it's
just short it's like a 22nd i think it's
more of a goof it's just like a goof
song it's not like
released but if it does get claimed
i apologize
[Music]
hold on baby
[Music]
shout out to the legend
this guy from my hometown g doulamoula
he uploaded a video checking out the
slide i just said
yeah
they speak fast
again we have the giants it's so loud
here i'll turn it down
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you need to show proof of vaccination or
of against tetanus push me push me push
me
push me push me push me lean forward
oh no the push is a bad idea i think
[Music]
oh this wasn't too fast
[Applause]
oh my god
[Applause]
man this is awesome this is kind of a
fire job like
super entertaining
all right
there it is
there it is there it is we've seen it
all we've done it all it's friday
baby woo
yeah
and we close out another week of four
full episodes here today is the h3
podcast
next week do we have anything
interesting going on next week
that's on friday that's on friday baby
okay that'll be fun
no it's it's pre-made
um
i'm the artist i envisioned it this way
in my head
i thought the flakka and the family
would be lined up
anyways we'll be back next week with
four more
fresh
episodes
every week
yes
yes yes
all right guys oh
ciao
you're watching h to the three three
[Music]
keep three change you filthy vlogger
[Music]